So Leute da bin ich, ich glaube wir brauchen noch mehr Emojis im Titel, Sekunde mehr Emoji
stellt. Klitzer, Klitzerstärlchen, so hier Spark, sehr gut. Webinterface modern. Wir
schreiben das umgedreht. Webinterface modern von 1500 Euro WLAN Access Point. Wobei Geld
lockt die Leute an, also lass ich lieber 1500 Euro Access Point drin stehen. Ich lass so
wie es ist. Die Stammzuschauer denen ist der Titel eh egal und die anderen werden eher
von 1500 Euro Access Point angelockt. Wobei es ist auch wirklich ein 1500 Euro Access Point.
Ja es ist ein 1500 Euro Access Point. Der kostet auf Ebay zwar nicht 1500, aber wenn
ihr ihn neu kauft kostet er 1500. Runde auf 2000 auf, der kostet aber nur 1500. Fake News
ist das sonst. Massive Fake News. Nachdem die Chinesen schon demnächst mit ihrem Spy
Ballon über Frankfurt spioniert haben und Chemtrails verteilt haben, da will ich jetzt
nicht auch noch Fake News verbreiten. Das geht ja nicht. Was ist das für ein Gerät?
Ich sag gleich was zu Leute. Ich warte jetzt erstmal bis der Stream richtig angelaufen
ist und Twitch das gecheckt hat. In der Zwischenzeit. Moment Leute. Ich muss mich erstmal beruhigen
wieder. So. Exzellent. Weil wenn ich gleich so super energisch, ach du Scheiße ich kann
euch mal deutsche Wörter mehr formulieren. Wenn ich super energisch den Stream anfange,
da tut mir der Hals nach einer halben Stunde weh. Das geht ja auch nicht. Heute bist du
tatsächlich früh. Ja. Also ich zeige euch gleich den Access Point und was wir machen
werden und sowas. Ich hab das hier alles schon hinter mir stehen. Ich erzähl euch kurz was
anderes, bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist. Gatschi Bass. Hyper Gatschi. Also Leute.
Ich erzähl euch jetzt mal was. Und zwar. Ich überleg grad welches davon. Welches davon
erzähl ich euch jetzt. Ich fang einfach mal an. Also Leute ich hab was auf der Arbeit
erlebt. Das hatte ich in diesem Ausmaß noch nicht. Gestern Morgen. Ihr wisst ja. Ich kümmer
mich da um neue Release Versionen und um unsere Git Repost und um unsere Server Konfiguration
und solche Geschichten. Ich hab da mal ein längliches Video drüber gemacht. Und wir
haben aktuell so ein kleines Problem. Und zwar. Nächste Woche gibt es was neues. Und
damit das neue funktioniert. Ich muss das ja immer so ein bisschen. Immer so ein bisschen
abstrakt erzählen. Ich kann jetzt hier nicht den Namen erzählen. Da wisst ihr alle was
ich meine. Achso größer machen das Ganze. Exzellent. So. Also zumindest nächste Woche
soll was eingeführt werden. Wozu es noch technische Änderungen auf dem Server bedarf.
Dass das funktioniert. Stellt es euch ein bisschen als Zertifikatstausch vor. Es ist
nicht wirklich ein Zertifikatstausch. Aber ein Zertifikatstausch kann man sich ganz gut
vorstellen. Was was halt wirklich zum Termin X da sein muss. So was in der Richtung. So.
Jetzt ist es so. Und das hab ich so in dieser Art und Weise in dieser Intensität noch nie
erlebt. Und zwar genau eingeführt wird das nächste Woche. Hyper Gatschi. Zumindest hab
ich das so noch nicht erlebt. Und zwar. Normalerweise haben wir zwei Leute. Oder besser gesagt einen
der die ganze Zeit dafür zuständig gewesen ist für dieses System. Und das sind jetzt
mittlerweile zwei. So. Und der eine soll das jetzt ein bisschen abgeben und der andere
soll es weiter machen. Zumindest lange Rede kurzer Sinn. Mittlerweile sind sie drei weil
sie lange Zeit genervt haben. Es kann doch nicht sein dass wir uns nur mit so wenig Personen
ohne Backup um so ein großes System kümmern müssen. Und jetzt sind es drei Leute. So.
Und der dritte den sie jetzt dabei bekommen haben. Der ist doch nicht so 100%ig. Ich muss
mal kurz die Musik ein bisschen. Der ist doch nicht so richtig eingearbeitet so 100%. Zumindest
ich glaube übrigens Teams hat meinen Sound verstellt. Der dritte ist doch nicht so 100%ig
eingearbeitet. Er sollte jetzt seinen ersten Change an diesem System machen. Und sein erster
Change ist gleichzeitig auch dieser Change der ganz wichtig ist für nächste Woche. Also
für nächste Woche wo das getauscht werden muss. So. Und jetzt kommt's. Also es dürfte
wahrscheinlich wieder beide Seiten. Der neue hat den Change nicht so ganz durchdacht. Der
hat auf der einen Seite viel zu viele Änderungen gemacht und auf der anderen Seite auch nicht
genug Änderungen. Also der Change war jetzt nicht so super durchdacht. Das Problem was
er hat ist er kann einfach nicht zugeben wenn er was verkehrt eingeschätzt hat. Also anstatt
zu sagen Jungs das ist das erste Mal dass ich das mache. Ich hab kaum Informationen
gekriegt. Ich guck's mir in Zukunft besser an. Dann wär eigentlich alles ok gewesen.
Kann er nicht. Also der hat instant in den Rausred Modus aktiviert nach dem Motto ich
hab den Change gemacht aber ich hab halt alles gedacht. So und die anderen beiden die sind
eh schon mega angepisst auf ihn wegen solchen Sachen. Haben ihm aber glaube ich auch nicht
alles wirklich 100%ig gut erklärt. Also ich denke mal es trifft beide Seiten so ein bisschen
dass es da jetzt schief gegangen ist. Wobei so komplett schief gegangen ist ist ja nichts
kaputt gegangen. Also ich glaube es trifft beide Seiten. Die einen haben sich richtig
erklärt und der andere hat halt ein bisschen zu offensiv selbstsicherer als es angemessen
war das ganze gemacht. Zumindest gestern morgen. Also was ich damit zu tun habe ist erst mal
gar nichts. Allerdings ich sorg ja dafür dass unsere ganzen Server auf dem aktuellen Stand
bleiben und auch aktuellste Config Änderungen kriegen. Das heißt das muss in unsere Server
Konfiguration rein. Ich meine wir haben über 4000 Linux Systeme und 4000 Linux Systeme administrierst
du nicht hier per Turnschuh von Hand oder auch per SSH alles von Hand. Also gibt's
Config Management System wo eingetragen wird quasi. Bei uns ist es allerdings nicht an
Ansible. Bei uns ist es noch Puppet zum größten Teil. Bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber wird es
lustigerweise wahrscheinlich dann zum größten Teil Ansible sein. Zumindest habe ich letzte
Woche versucht das einzuspielen und habe festgestellt wenn wir das einspielen dann geht's kaputt.
Es sind mehrere Sachen. Ein Zertifikat fehlt. Config war nicht richtig. Manche Änderungen
nicht getestet. Also ganz blöder Zustand was man nicht unbedingt auf seinem produktiven
Live System haben will. So letzte Woche festgestellt habe ich letzte Woche mit Ihnen zusammen
bis Nachmittags da gesessen. Also es hätte Donnerstag Freitag. Donnerstag auf Freitagnacht
hätte das ganze noch mal ausgeführt werden können. Wir haben Donnerstag bis 16.30 Uhr
oder so da gehockt und daran rum gebastelt und es hat nicht funktioniert. Da habe ich
gesagt wisst ihr was wir lassen es bleiben. Übers Wochenende will ich das nicht laufen
haben und wir machen das nächste Woche. Also nächste Woche war jetzt diese Woche. Wir müssen
es diese Woche machen weil wir brauchen das nächste Woche für andere Changes ist das
die Voraussetzung. Okay. So und wie gesagt es war ein Riesen hin und her. Dann hat der
Neue noch mal versucht nachzubessern. Die anderen haben wieder reingeredet und es ging
ein Riesen hin und her war das. Zumindest das gipfelte dann darin dass ich gestern Morgen
auf ein Meeting eingeladen wurde wo es eigentlich darum gehen soll. Ich kann euch ja sagen grob
was es geht. Es geht um Änderungen für E-Mail Versand. Ihr könnt euch vorstellen E-Mail
Sachen selbst zu betreiben ist eh schon ein wahnsinnig komplexes, komplettes PPGAS System
wo keiner so richtig durm ist. Es geht um E-Mail Versand. So dann wurde ich eingeladen gestern
Morgen um 9 Uhr rum wo wir dann diesen Fix besprechen wollten dass wir den dann Mittwoch
auf Donnerstag Nacht einspielen können dass dann nächste Woche die Voraussetzungen erfüllt
sind. So und morgens gehe ich in das Meeting rein und anstatt dass wir den Fix besprechen
haben die sich erstmal ohne Scheiß 45 Minuten extrem angekackt die drei also wirklich. Ich
hab das noch nie erlebt die haben sich so extrem angekackt. Also der Neue hat sich permanent
raus geredet anstatt zu sagen ja ich hab nicht richtig geguckt das hat die anderen beiden
unglaublich getriggert und ihr müsst euch vorstellen zwischenzeitlich vielen dann so
was. Also ich kann irgendwo ich kann beide Seiten ein bisschen ein bisschen nachvollziehen
ich kann beide Seiten ein bisschen nachvollziehen also der Neue hat sich nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert
mit dem Change vor allem dass er da auch im Vorfeld nicht ordentlich gefragt hat und nicht
richtig nachgeguckt an sowas und die anderen verstehe ich auch irgendwie die geht halt
auf den Sack dass sie sich drum kümmern müssen sie haben es auch schon gesagt sowas. Guckt
ihr mal das Projekt an YouTube als Cloud Speicher missbrauchen. Ok Moment gucken wir uns gleich
an. So zumindest da ging es dann worauf ich raus will da ging es dann auf einmal dahin
dass sie sich nicht nur angekackt haben auf einmal auf einmal und da muss ich jetzt da
muss ich jetzt den hier einblenden auf einmal meinte dann der eine so nach dem Motto du machst
nie wieder was an einem produktiven System ich verbiete dir das jetzt. So nicht wortwörtlich
Zitat aber war schon war schon da dran und da habe ich gesagt alter was ist denn jetzt
los hier komplett am eskalieren alles und da kam eine andere das kann ich so aber nicht
kann ich so aber nicht stehen lassen und das ist und ihr habt es mir überhaupt nicht richtig
gezeigt ernst alter ich wusste gar nicht dass da so ausrasten kann dabei ich wusste
gar nicht dass er in diesem ausrasten Modus überhaupt umschalten kann ich habe den noch
nie ausrasten sehen den Typ. Naja zumindest wie gesagt ich kann sie schon irgendwie ich
kann schon irgendwie verstehen zumindest waren sie extrem sauer zumindest waren sie auch
zurecht ja muss man sagen da war schon schon was dran ist nicht einfach nur weil sie weil
man mal raging will oder so. So und heute und heute kommt der Hit heute kommt der Hit also
gestern wurde ihm quasi untersagt er soll er soll nichts mehr machen ans System wobei
ich mich halt frage das ist ja nicht sein Vorgesetzter da kann das eigentlich gar nicht
entscheiden außerdem wenn er nichts mehr auf produktiven System machen soll was soll
er denn dann arbeiten gut egal heute nächstes Meeting nächster Versuch für die für diesen
Change es geht immer nur letztendlich die Änderung im Konfig Management ohne Scheiß
das waren sieben Zeilen oder so also wir reden hier von sieben Zeilen Text und die Zeilen
sind auch nicht lang die Zeilen sind 30 40 Zeichen lang also wir reden hier von ganz
ganz kleinen Änderungen nichts wildes ja paar paar Charakter austauschen aber riesen
Ding. Danke schön für den Sub. So und heute heute ging es weiter zweite Runde dazu und
ich gehe in das Meeting rein und ich wundere mich schon kurz warum der warum der neue nicht
bei dem Meeting mit dabei ist denke mir na wo ist der denn hin ich habe es nicht gesagt
ich habe es nicht gesagt ich habe mich nur schon gewundert wo ist der denn wo ist er
denn und und dann und dann fragte mich ne ne ne ne dann fragte mich der eine max du kennst
dich doch mit mit dem VPN aus bei uns er sagt ja ich habe da schon mal Leute für freischalten
lassen warum ich wir nennen den neuen jetzt einfach mal Peter weil ich muss jetzt den
Namen sagen ja er heißt nicht Peter also und er meinte so ja kannst du mal den Peter für
das VPN sperren also Peter ist der neue das erste was ich in diesem Video weiß Max kannst
du mal den Peter für das VPN sperren also ich kann ihn ich kann ihn selbst nicht sperren
ich kann ihn nur sagen wo man das wo man das beantragen muss und sowas ja in die und die
Gruppe und da wollten die den wirklich den Zugriff auf die Systeme sperren also soweit
soweit ging es da schon aus so und dann im Laufe des Tages habe ich gehört der neue
ist auch wohl demnächst nicht mehr da oder sowas alter was auch ey da flie sind die Fetzen
geflogen ich sags euch ne da war die sind nicht umsonst so stinkig gewesen ne ne ne ne
die sind nicht umsonst so stinkig gewesen da hat schon paar Sachen nicht ganz ordnungsgemäß
gemacht bei deinem neuen nein nein nein bei meinem alten bei meinem jetzigen am 1.
April bin ich erst beim neuen meine so ich muss echt sagen ich bin jetzt über 10 Jahre
in dieser in diesem Unternehmen ich habe noch nie bei einem Meeting es gab schon es gab
schon öfters mal richtig Sachen wo die Fetzen geflogen sind ja aber 45 Minuten lang über
zwei Tage hinweg die Fetzen geflogen das habe ich noch nicht erlebt also die sind wirklich
die können sich nicht ab und das wird auch nichts mehr zum Thema Review in Abnahme da
habe ich letztes habe ich mein letztes Video fasst das ganz gut zusammen den Status unserer
Test Umgebung achso Moment in dem Fall in dem Fall ist es tatsächlich in Abnahme auch
kaputt gegangen nicht dass ich nicht dass ich jetzt müssen jetzt ist in Abnahme auch
kaputt gegangen das war ja auch eines der Kritikpunkte von ihnen dass es in Abnahme
kaputt gegangen ist und der neue wohl nicht ordnungsgemäß also also wohl nicht richtig
darauf reagiert hat und das ordentlich gefixt hat es ist in Abnahme kaputt gegangen obskure
Gestalt es ist in Abnahme kaputt gegangen und den zweiten Teil den zweiten Teil der
Änderungen mit Zertifikatswechsel ja gut das kannst du nicht so wirklich testen weil
logischerweise die Zertifikate unterschiedlich sind aber man könnte das machen ja man könnte
sicherlich irgendwie die gleichen Domains verwenden Abnahme und Live Umgebung und sowas
aber ist da nicht so die Zertifikate sind eh unterschiedlich also das Zertifikat selbst
kannst du nicht testen aber die restlichen Änderungen kannst du testen und die sind
in Abnahme auch kaputt gegangen okay zwei zwei Stunden zwei Stunden ist natürlich auch
schon lang naja zumindest die Fronten sind verhärtet und das tja achja und heute Mittag
Leute ich hab ich bin ja auch ein bisschen auf den Keks gegangen die letzten Tage und
gesagt wir müssen das jetzt machen für nächste Woche ja und die wollen das ja auch haben
der Change jetzt kommt heute Mittag also ich habe ihnen heute Morgen gesagt so neuesten
Fix habe ich fertig habe ich überall Git technisch hingepusht steht in allen Environments
zur Verfügung ihr könnt es jetzt testen heute morgen um neun meinte meinte dann eine
ja ich teste das jetzt bis mittags 14 Uhr habe ich nichts mehr davon gehört habe ich
gesagt ja wie sieht es denn jetzt aus mit dem Test heute Nacht 23 Uhr soll das passieren
so mal mal gucken ob es jetzt geht wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt das wird heute Abend ausgeführt
und dann hatten wir 15 Uhr 30 haben wir noch einen Call gemacht in Teams und haben uns
den Change angeguckt und wisst ihr was rausgekommen ist ratet mal was ist rausgekommen es ist
immer noch kaputt es geht mehr als vorher es geht mehr als vorher es geht quasi zu
95 prozent aber was jetzt aufgefallen ist deswegen deswegen habe ich jetzt auch an Zertifikate
gedacht was jetzt aufgefallen ist jetzt kommt jetzt kommt es also change also config management
technisch und und konfiguration technisch ist alles ok jetzt ist ihnen allerdings aufgefallen
dass sie für eine Domain vergessen haben das Zertifikat zu beantragen und dementsprechend
kann das heute Nacht dann doch nicht ausgeführt werden weil du kannst ja nicht ausführen
weil du hast kein Zertifikat da muss ich das für heute Nacht wieder absagen und jetzt
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt sie haben morgen morgen haben sie noch Zeit weil nächste
Woche spätestens Montag Abend nächste Woche muss das fertig sein ja ja das passiert manchmal
das wirst du das wirst du nicht vorbeugen können im Endeffekt es erzählen dir dann
alles und achte Motto ja mit ordentlichem Zertifikats management und ordentliche Monitoring
und bla bla bla bla bla in der Theorie die Leute die das erzählen haben noch nie festgestellt
dass es immer wenn du irgendwo bist und mal eine Woche nicht hinguckst zwei neue Systeme
gibt also ja in der Theorie kannst du der Sache alles vorbeugen in der Praxis wird
es wahrscheinlich immer mal das eine andere geben was was durch durchrutscht wobei man
ja sagen muss so rein wissenschaftlich gesehen ist dieser Vergleich den man immer so bringt
ja der Unterschied zwischen Theorie und Praxis so rein wissenschaftlich gesehen ist das
natürlich eigentlich blödsinnig ja wissenschaftlich gesehen heißt es ja wenn du eine Theorie hast
dann hast du irgendwie eine Beschreibung eines Sachverhaltes die im besten Fall voraussagen
trifft also sprich wenn ich in der Praxis x mache dann passiert y und dann kann ich
in der Praxis x machen und wenn dann y passiert dann ist die Theorie gut und wenn dann z
passiert ist die Theorie kacke also im Umgang sprachlich verwendet man es ja so Theorie
und Praxis immer so Sachen die sich gut anhören aber dann praktisch nicht so funktionieren
das geht doch eigentlich gar nicht hast du nicht drei monaten cool down auf oder zwei
monate cool down auf dem Domain bis man die sich neu registrieren kann da gibt es auch
da gibt es auch so eine Übergangszeit wo das nicht geht so eigentlich euch jetzt ich zeige
euch ach Moment Sekunde vorher muss ich euch noch was anderes erzählen dass ich nicht
nachher wieder krass gesight tracked werde ja ihr habt doch wahrscheinlich mal Hände
hoch wenn man letztes Video gesehen hat kommt auf den Registrat ich dachte eigentlich dass
es doch sein muss dass die ja ja channel ich zeige euch gleich den nächsten wir hatten
mein letztes video gesehen ich vermute mal die ein oder andere haben das gemacht ja da
ging es ja auch da ging es ja um einen ausfall den wir hatten vor zwei wochen vor vor einer
woche ungefähr einen ausfall den wir hatten und ich habe in dem video gesagt ich bin mal
gespannt auf die Retrospektive zu diesem zu diesem Fehler und die Retrospektive war vor
gestern und heute Leute ich muss euch sagen was in dieser Retrospektive steht ach so übrigens
das was ich im video gesagt habe ist falsch es war kein namensauflösungsproblem obwohl
man ja eigentlich sagt dass es immer namensauflösungsprobleme sind aber in jedem Fall war es nicht wie
im video gesagt ein namensauflösungsproblem sondern ein firewall netzwerkproblem tatsächlich
es hat mit dns nichts zu tun gehabt ich habe vermutet dass es dns ist in dem video es war
nicht dns es war netzwerk firewall problematik nee den neowimp stream haben wir nicht gemacht
so und zumindest war dann die Retrospektive und in der Retrospektive steht quasi alles
unwichtige drin aber nix von dem oder wenig von dem was ich für wichtig halte das im prinzip
genauso wie ich es in dem video angesprochen habe zumal der typ der die Retrospektive geschrieben
hat absolut keinen bock hatte der hat sich mega gelangweilt und und kein bock angehört
so da muss ich jetzt auch was reinschreiben was schreibe ich da der hat überhaupt kein
bock gehabt ich habe zum beispiel in der Retrospektive angesprochen wie kann es sein dass ein
test für die live umgebung sagt es würde alles funktionieren aber ein als ultra wichtig
definierter service nicht funktionieren der test trotzdem ok ist wisst ihr was die antwort
war beste beste business beste business antwort aller zeiten die man darauf gegeben hat also
es war so das ist was kurz kurz ganz kurze zwei minuten zusammenfassung für alle die
es nicht gesehen die es nicht gesehen haben bei uns bei mir auf der arbeit was kaputt
gegangen in dem fall sah es wirklich so aus ist es aber nicht
ja also genau genau also ganz ganz kurze minuten gesagt für alles video nicht gesehen bei
mir auf der arbeit ist was kaputt gegangen und es gibt ein test der immer morgens von
unserem support ausgeführt wird morgens ungefähr vier uhr fünf uhr morgens wird der test ausgeführt
es ist ein test der heißt sinngemäß der hat hinter ein bisschen andere namen aber sinngemäß
heißt dieser test wenn du ihn ausführst test aller live services und es ist nachts ein
service kaputt gegangen der laut unsere management essenziell wichtig ist für unseren dass der
außendienst arbeiten kann es ist quasi eines unser management hat definiert dass es eines
der wichtigsten services ist die wir haben da würde man natürlich von ausgehen wenn
man einen test hat der sich nennt test aller live services dass damit auch einer der wichtigsten
services die wir haben getestet wird also könnte man anhand des namens und der wichtigkeit
schon von ausgehen ja ist aber nicht so der test läuft ohne fehler durch obwohl der service
down war und sagt am ende noch kriege daumen hoch alles gut funktioniert das hat natürlich
auch nicht dazu beigetragen dass man den fehler sonderlich schnell erkannt hat so und das
habe ich gesagt auf dieser retrospektive habe ich sagt ja leute also es gab drei punkte wie
man das ohne probleme hätte vermeiden können und der erste punkt davon ist unser unser
live umgebungstest der teste den service nicht obwohl es eines der wichtigsten services ist
die wir haben also wie kann das sein das sollten wir auf jeden fall in die nacharbeiten was
nach der retrospektive passieren muss mit rein dass das klar ist dass es wieder mal ein fall
war wo dieser unvollständige test dazu geführt hat das ist ja seit jahren schon so wo dieser
unvollständige test dazu geführt hat dass man fehler nicht er nicht erkannt hat so und
wisst ihr was die antwort war warum warum das nicht in die retrospektive reingeschrieben
wird die antwort war ach max das müssen wir eigentlich nicht aufführen weil da haben
wir anderweitig schon eine maßnahme laufen der test wird ja angepasst das erzählen sie
seit fünf jahren mann der test wird nie angepasst wir haben da eine maßnahme laufen da weißt
du bescheid er meint dass derjenige das gesagt hat meint es überhaupt nicht bös also dem
würde ich da würde ich da nichts unterstellen ist tatsächlich als der fähigste leute in
richtung change management die wir haben ich glaube sie aber trotzdem nicht dass jemals
dieser smoke test dieser live test geht im leben nicht so nächster punkt war den ich
angebracht habe unser monitoring wirft laufen falsch meldungen man kann echt eine meldung
von falsch meldungen nicht mehr unterscheiden teilweise steht in der retrospektive gar
nicht drinne wurde einfach wurde einfach ignored und der andere fall dass unsere testing umgebung
anders ist als die live umgebung ist deswegen auch nicht gemerkt wurde steht auch nicht
drinne also alles worauf es wirklich ankommt steht irgendwie nicht drinne kein schimmer
was da was mit dem wieder los ist also die retrospektive hat sie überhaupt nicht gelohnt
und der retrospektiven schreiber hat überhaupt kein bock die retrospektive zu schreiben also
typischer business enterprise wahnsinn es ist definitiv nicht blazingly fast written
in rust bei uns es ist eher so bei uns wobei ich den mein faschings faschings emote auch
mal raus machen kann ok alles klar jetzt kann ich euch den access point zeigen und das was
wir heute machen
cobalt ist auch so ein dauerbrenner cobalt ist auch so ein dauerbrenner ihr sagt ja immer
cobalt so sinnbildlich wenn der chat was von cobalt sagt weil nicht von cobalt also von
cobalt dann ist das ja für den chat immer synonym für zeug aus der steinzeit so im
endeffekt aber soll ich euch mal was sagen wie gesagt ich arbeite bei einer bank und
wir haben cobalt wir haben auch noch ibm ibm mainframes und sowas so und jetzt ja die machen
das immer noch wir haben wir haben noch einige cobalt sachen das problem ist nur dass diese
alt dieses ganze alte cobalt zeug so ohne weiteres nicht läuft deswegen haben wir seit
einer weile schon eine eine software die übersetzt cobalt nach java beziehungsweise jeder stimmt
glaube ich nicht die kompiliert das cobalt zeug quasi in jvm kompatiblen bytecode dass
es java ausführen kann also ganz wirres zeug ja aber uns ist cobalt immer noch angesagt
cobalt entwickler sind wahrscheinlich ultra reich so ich zeige euch mal den access point
um was es heute geht so schaut mal hier ich habe mir ja vor einer weile diesen access
point gekauft oder diese access point hier gekauft naja gut 1500 euro stimmt nicht so
ganz 1367 euro allerdings wohlgemerkt bei ebay sind die deutlich billiger ich hätte
die bestimmt nicht zum neu preis gekauft aber man ist selten deswegen steht das in
meinem twitch titel heute drin also man kriegt das so zwischen 1000 und 1500 euro wenn man
mal bei ebay guckt wenn man mal bei ebay guckt er nicht z r 710 so viel ibm zeug die sind
auch teurer geworden also ich habe meinen gekriegt zwischen ein habe ich richtig günstig
gekriegt für irgendwie 100 130 euro und dann habe ich noch einen anderen für 180 bis 200
irgendwie also ich habe irgendwas zwischen 130 und 200 euro für die für die drei stück
bezahlt also ich habe ich habe einen r 710, einen r 510 und einen r 610 alles die gleiche
alles die gleiche generation allerdings für unterschiedlich viele user und so ausgelegt
aktuell ist es bei mir so ich habe einen r 710 um bei mir im wohnzimmer hängen und
r 510 unten im keller und hier neben mir hier ist er leute hier achtung access point asmr
r 610 den habe ich für so für solche sachen wie hier dass wir im streamer was basteln
können und zum ausprobieren habe ich die tribo und danke für den sub glaube ich habe
jede menge habe ich habe ich sab zu übersehen macht es hat auch nicht blim gemacht im hintergrund
ne habe ich nicht dankeschön ich habe ich schon gesehen trotzdem porno subscription leute
kurz gucken wie viele subs habe ich eigentlich aktuell mal wieder subscription raten machen
was denn da los es ist wieder getroppt ein bisschen das obwohl ich so viel gestreamt habe
in letzter zeit zu wenig zu wenig primus am start wollen weniger leute bezahs was überweisen
es ist auch gut ja nice bald kein dankeschön für den sub so wo sind wir stehen geblieben
du sagst immer du brauchst keine ich brauche auch keine wenn du brauchen definierst wie
ich muss für hungern ich muss euch nicht erzählen leute ich muss verhungern wenn ich eure prime
subs nicht gegen aber ernsthaft wenn ihr wenn ihr amazon prime habt dann haut euren prime
sub irgendwo raus es muss auch nicht bei mir sein aber benutzt den prime sub weil im endeffekt
ist es sonst geschenktes geld könnt ihr dann könnt ihr quasi bezahs nächsten weltallflug
mitfinanzieren gibt es lieber irgendein streamer den ihr gerne zuguckt das kann auch jemand
kleines sein gerade kleines firma also sogar ich bin ja auch nicht groß ja aber es gibt
ja durchaus streamer die haben irgendwie nur 15 15 zuschauer und die freuen sich richtig
den ast ab wenn ihr den prime sub gibt das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar mal gesehen
für die ist das für die ist die ist quasi der tag wenn ich die woche gerettet jetzt
nicht monetär geld technisch gesehen weil die können sich davon jetzt ja auch nicht
großartiges leisten aber die freuen sich einfach richtig den ast ab das heißt lasst
euren prime sub auf jeden fall nicht verfallen das ist das was ich sagen wollte ich meine
ich freue mich selbstverständlich über jeden prime sub ich habe da nichts dagegen wenn
ihr euren prime sub gebt da freue ich mich drüber aber lasst ihn nicht verfallen ob
ihn nur mir gibt oder jemand anderem ist ja wurscht so also muss überstehen geblieben
genau ich habe mehr 710 510 er 610 und warum ich mir die gekauft habe das werde ich euch
jetzt dann auch im web interface zeigen aber ich sage erst mal was dazu und zwar so sehen
die dinge aus die sehen aus wie man sich so einen access point vorstellt graue kiste aus
plastik graue kiste aus plastik aus recht hochwertig gut verarbeiteten plastik also
die dinger sind ordentlich ordentlich stabil dass da unten diese nippel den man da sieht
ist dafür da dass man den an die decke klipsen kann und sowas ich habe mir dafür habe ich
irgendwo irgendwo hatte ich auch mal ein bild finde ich jetzt nicht mehr ich hatte ich habe
mir nämlich von von singiverse habe ich mir eine halterung ausgedruckt für den r710
was singiverse habe ich mir eine halterung ausgedruckt für den für den access point
und habe ihn unter der decke gemountet decke decke im wohnzimmer allerdings habe ich den
access point nicht an diesen plastik nippeln hängen sondern ich habe wieder so inserts
reingeschmolzen mit dem lötkolben und dann reingeschraubt und das hält wirklich bombenfest
das hängt da hängt da schon jetzt drei vierteljahr oder so juckt es überhaupt nicht so und warum
ich mir den gekauft habe das kann ich euch auch noch mal kurz erklären also sprich warum
ich zwei jetzt mit dem jetzt zusammen drei diese access points am start habe das liegt
hauptsächlich an den features was für ein 3d drucker ich habe ein i3 mega s würde ich
jetzt nicht mehr kaufen gibt es schon bessere neue aber damals war es ein super einsteiger
modell und preisleistungstechnisch immer noch ziemlich gut so ein habe ich any cubic i3
mega s muss man für ruckus ruckus oder ruckus wie auch immer man die ausspricht nicht einen
controller haben nein mit unleashed nicht unleashed ist die standalone firmware von
denen erzähle ich gleich was zu wenn wir uns das angucken
so warum ich das gekauft habe kann ich euch auch noch kurz erzählen das ist ja kein wirklicher
mainstream access point also erste mal ist es kein mainstream access point weil die dinger
neu 1367 euro kosten wohlgemerkt der r710 ist auch nicht das aktuelle modell das aktuelle
modell ist glaube ich der r760 oder gibt es schon einen neueren glaub der r760 ist das
aktuelle modell der ist noch etwas günstiger zu haben der kostet dann nur 2263 euro also
quasi fast fast geschenkt wir können auch mal gucken was der was der r750 hey da wird
er wieder wieder wieder wieder wieder billiger als der kram ist der kram ist unglaublich
teuer das würde ich würde ich mir halt neu würde ich mir neu auch nicht nicht kaufen
das ist total bescheuert ich habe mir die alte die alte generation auf ebay gekauft wohlgemerkt
die neuen sind natürlich i triple i 802.11ax also wi-fi 6 und ganz neuen können vielleicht
auch wi-fi 6e oder sowas schon meiner kann nur wi-fi also 802.11ac ne was kam vor ax
802.11ac also das was wi-fi 5 das was unter wi-fi 5 läuft normalerweise an an ist noch
älter davor gab es b und n und so keiner ja also das ist wi-fi 5 aber das reicht ja
im heimbereich sind nicht so als macht es einen großen unterschied wenn ich hier bei
dem access point stehe habe ich irgendwie 330 mbit oder sowas das flutscht richtig also
kannst du dich überhaupt nicht beschweren so zumindest warum ich mir das gekauft habe
jetzt kommt der eigentliche knackpunkt das ist ja kein mainstream access point ich kenne
außer mir niemand hier in deutschland der überhaupt ruckus x ruckus access point hat
und im heimbereich schon gar nicht warum ich mir gekauft habe ist folgendes ich hatte vorher
unify unify die habe ich auch noch hier im schrank liegen da hatte ich drei stück glaube
ich unify ich glaube ich glaube unify hatte ich sogar vier stück ich hatte einen hier
bei mir im arbeitszimmer stehen ich hatte einen unten im wohnzimmer stehen ich hatte
einen auf der anderen seite vom haus stehen richtung richtung garten und terrasse und
ich hatte einen unten im keller stehen so verteilt dass es sich möglichst wenig überlappt
im keller muss halt einer hin mein keller ist ziemlich massiv da kommen die signale
nicht gut durch deswegen habe ich da jetzt auch noch noch ein extra extra entstehen
aber ich habe glücklicherweise die möglichkeit dort netzwerkabel hin hin zu bekommen so ich
habe größere probleme mit unify gehabt was die abdeckung angeht was ich nicht so genau
verstanden habe ich mein selbst mit eins bis zwei access points sollte es eigentlich gut
abgedeckt sein wobei man sagen muss hier ist halt viel wifi traffic drum herum los ich habe
aber auch die bänder so gewählt dass es eigentlich ganz gut passt aber die die abdeckung und
die stabilität war jetzt nicht unbedingt mein haupt kritikpunkt an unify das hat schon
ganz brauchbar funktioniert was mir ein bisschen auf den keks gegangen ist war einmal so die
philosophie bei unify was was das ui und die ui-änderung angeht aber vor allem dass ich
mir bei dem unify zeug nie so richtig sicher war ist das jetzt ist es jetzt für heim anwender
gedacht oder ist es für profis gedacht auf der einen seite für profis ist es zu unprofessionell
und für heim anwender ist auf der anderen seite oftmals zu nichts sagen das habe ich
nicht so genau verstanden an was ich unify jetzt eigentlich genau richten will aber das
ist ja ok kann man sich ja irgendwie einarbeiten das war nicht das problem mein hauptproblem
an unify war dass es dass sie features die viele andere hersteller haben und die ich
auch gerne gehabt hätte nicht unterstützen und mein hauptfeature schlechthin was ich
unbedingt benutzen will ist unterschiedliche wlan passwörter für unterschiedliche geräte
das können die also die großen hersteller können es eigentlich alle mikrotik sogar
kann das allerdings mikrotik hat naja mikrotik typisch nicht die simpelste konfig dafür
und haben auch ein paar einschränkungen aber mikrotik kann das auch es können eigentlich
mehr oder weniger alle also hier rugus kanns mikrotik kanns meraki zeug kanns was gibt
es da sonst noch da gibt es auch was mit a open wrt kann es mittlerweile auch allerdings
ist open wrt auch ein bisschen ein bisschen problematisch noch was das ui angeht habe
ich gelesen ich ausprobieren wie heißt sie a wlan hersteller mit a aurora nee eros und
nee aruba aruba genau ja die können das alle da heißt es dann entweder dynamic dpsk mpsk
irgendwie was auch immer die haben alle unterschiedliche namen dafür aber die meinen mehr oder weniger
das gleiche und zwar dass du eine ssid hast und unterschiedliche passwörter für unterschiedliche
geräte warum ist das nützlich das ist nützlich wenn du zum beispiel ich wollte gerade eigentlich
was viel zu kompliziertes sagen es ist noch viel naheliegender wenn du zum beispiel in
gäste wlan hast ja klar in gäste wlan kann man auch mit anmelde portal und sowas machen
aber zum beispiel wenn ihr den gäste wlan habt oder ab und zu besuch und ihr könnt den
einfach ein qr code in die hand drücken und die scan das ein und sind bei euch im netz
und danach verfällt den ihr zugang wieder ist schon nice und mit zugang verfallen ist
nicht gemeint dass einfach alles geplockt wird wie das bei beispielsweise einem portal
mit anmeldung ist nee nee der zugang ist da nicht mehr gültig die kommen nicht mehr
ins ins ins netzwerk weil eben ihr account beziehungsweise ihr password verfällt also
die gehen dann in ihre netzwerk settings und geben in ihre netzwerk settings die ssid und
ein password ein dass das password allerdings nur für dieses gerät beziehungsweise für
diesen user gilt und wenn ihr das password oder wenn ihr das quasi dann löscht dann
kommen die nicht mehr ins wlan nicht so nach dem motto sie können sich anmelden kommen
aber nicht mehr hin weil sie keinen gültigen voucher token was auch immer haben sie kommen
nicht mehr ins wlan aber wofür ich das ganze haben will ist ich habe jede menge iot geräte
ich ich habe jede menge iot geräte und da ist es halt so dass in jeder müsst ihr euch
mal vorstellen in jeder poplichen wlan glühbirne jetzt triggert es bestimmt wieder manche
leute dass ich glühbirne sage aber mir ist das lieber als leuchtmittel in jeder poplichen
glühbirne wlan wifi glühbirne ist meine ssid und mein wlan password drinnen ja ich
habe ein iot netzwerk aber trotzdem der ansatz gefällt mir nicht die geräte dürfen trotzdem
ein bisschen was machen mir gefällt der ansatz nicht in jeder steckdose in jedem tablet in
jedem smartphone überall ist die ssid und das wlan password drin und es ist für alle
geräte das gleiche das heißt im endeffekt auch sollte ich mein gerät wegschmeißen und
es nicht ordentlich schreddern theoretisch könnte jemand aus dem speicher easy mein wlan
password auslesen die chancen dass das jemand macht will ich jetzt will ich jetzt nicht
übertrieben irgendwie herbeireden oder so ja also es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
irgendjemand an meinen müll geht dann einen weggeschmissenen esp 32 rausholt und dann
irgendwie da mein wlan password raus extrahiert aber ich finde doof dass es vom ansatz her
ohne probleme möglich ist so und deswegen will ich unbedingt exis points haben die eben
unterschiedliche passwörter für unterschiedliche geräte unterstützen wie gesagt die größten
hersteller können alle außer unify unify hat keinen bock es gibt es gibt schon ewigkeiten
oder ppsk die nennen es alle unterschiedlicher es gibt schon es gibt schon ewig seit ewigkeits
anfragen an ubiquity ob die das ob die das nicht mal machen können alle anderen hersteller
haben es aber ubiquity denkt sich nö habe ich eigentlich wie würde jemand wissen wo
du wohnst ja gut das ist ja da sind wir ja schon ein bisschen so bei security obscurity
und sowas in der richtung so security by obscurity so nach dem motto ja ich habe mein password
aber ihr wisst nicht wo ich wohne um ins wlan reinzukommen das ist natürlich auch vom ansatz
her schon nicht sonderlich schlauer gelöst dann aber es ist doch blöd dass es ohne dass
es theoretisch ohne probleme möglich ist also es gibt jede menge anfragen hier beispielsweise
an ubiquity dass die und die haben die haben einfach kein bock die wollen das nicht ja
das ist schon kommt auch immer wieder aber die die wollen nicht das juckt die nicht
wie gesagt obwohl das obwohl das echt ein super nice feature ist und wenn mikrotik den krempel
schon kann mikrotik kostet ein viertel von unify und tp link kann es auch dieses oma
da zeug von tp link kann das auch also es gibt überhaupt keinen grund das nicht zu
implementieren und es ist ein sehr sinnvolles feature ja es manche leute haben selbst was
gestrickt oder so doch und das ist der hauptgrund warum ich dieses ding benutze und das ist
ein mega nice feature ich wüsste ich wüsste gar nicht mehr ich würde mir nichts mehr
anschaffen was dieses feature nicht mehr unterstützt und das ist der grund oder der hauptgrund
warum ich unify rausgeschmissen hat mit zwei access points davon gekauft habe so und der
heutige stream der wird sich auch genau darum drehen nämlich was ist hier nämlich also
ich benutze das feature schon eine ganze weile ich zeige euch das bevor ich lange laber ich
zeige euch das jetzt einfach mal wir machen die vm an ich zeige euch ich schließe ich
schließe den access point an übergang zum sponsor nein ich werde nicht gesponsert ich
würde mich gern von den sponsoren lassen haupts habe ich jetzt wieder auf runterladen
gedrückt ich hoffe nicht naja ich würde mich gerne von den sponsoren lassen weil dann würde
ich zwei neue r760 bekommen und dafür ein bisschen shout out machen da wäre ich sofort
dabei easy sellout easy live so erst erstmal kurz eine runde os update ich meine wir haben
ein rolling release da müssen wir auch rollen gachi bass reboot schreibt die doch mal an
hey so sehr reiße ich mich da um sponsorship sachen auch nicht es tut ja alles quatsch
mit soße moin also hat man verstanden was was ich meine mit diesem unterschiedliche
passwörter für das gleiche wlan also nicht ich meine damit nicht dass man die möglichkeit
mehrere ssid aufzumachen das kann man ja sogar mit der fritzbox machen wobei kann man das
mit der fritzbox machen zumindest kann man wahrscheinlich mit den meisten access points
machen mehrere ssid aufmachen aber es geht mir nicht um mehrere ssid geht mir um die
gleiche ssid und trotzdem unterschiedliche passwörter für unterschiedliche geräte
und auch ich rede auch nicht von wpa enterprise mit radioserver und sowas ne ne ganz normales
klassisches pre-shared key modernifizierung für wpa 2 allerdings pro gerät take viagra
da ja danke schön für den sub
so jetzt zeige ich euch das mal also ich mache mal den access point an und ich hoffe mein
dhcp gibt ihm wieder die gleiche ip wie vorher wenn ich muss gleich mal in meinen router gucken
eins vier sechs hatte das ging definitiv zu schnell das ging definitiv zu schnell dann
hat sich die ip schon immer ein anderes geschnappt da muss ich mal kurz in meinen router gucken
dhcp leases
ah meine vm meine vm hat sich die ip jetzt geschnappt ok da muss ich mal kurz warten
bis im dhcp jetzt der access pointer auf aufschlägt rambo danke schön für den sub ich kann
jetzt gerade nicht in den chat gucken ich muss ich muss ein auger auf meine dhcp reservierung
haben eins vier neun das könnte das könnte er sein ja das sieht gut aus das ist der access
point wieder den neuen access point gekauft ne den habe ich schon eine weile also das
ist aus der gleichen generation wie die zwei die ich hier betreibe daheim ich habe ja hier
einen r 710 im kellern r 510 was wir hier zum testen haben ist ein r 610 ich hatte damals
auf ebay welche bestellt ich brauche alle ich brauche ja nur zwei aber ich hatte damals
bei ebay mehr bestellt weil ich da weil ich nicht sicher war ob das alles passt alles
ankommt und auf einmal hatte ich ein zu viel was aber nicht schlecht ist weil da kann man
ein bisschen im stream mit rumbasteln und ich muss ich an meinem live access point konfig rumdoktern
matrix danke schön für den sub so jetzt gucken wir mal ob der access point am start ist eins
und zwei 2.149 ok der webserver ist noch nicht gestartet jetzt aha advanced accept risk admin
oh fuck alle mein password man was weiß ich ich konnte ich wurde kurz clipboard ausschalten
admin password ja safe aber leute ich spiele ja blind hier ja und ist das beste ja so jetzt
sind wir im webinterface von von dem access point und jetzt kann ich euch ja theoretisch
mal ein paar sachen zeigen und mal kurz das clipboard wieder an kann ich ja theoretisch
mal ein paar sachen zeigen also man braucht dafür anders als bei unify braucht man keinen
extra controller und zwar das funktioniert hier drüber bla bla bla bla references oh
fuck man wo ist das system muss ich jetzt mal suchen ich klicke da so selten drin rum
das funktioniert ohne controller das funktioniert ohne controller ein access point macht automatisch
controller mit sieht man das hier ach das sieht man nicht weil ich nur ein access point
in dieser gruppe drin habe deswegen wird das nicht angezeigt ok alles klar also hier das
geht glaube ich bis bis zu 100 126 oder so access points in so einer group wenn man ein
unify access point hat braucht man trotzdem ein controller ja ja braucht man hier kann
hier kannst du quasi in den access point dazu abstellen gleichzeitig access point und controller
mitzumachen seit der neuesten software version kann man wohl auch dedicated controller machen
mit einem access point so und hier sieht man halt so die alle möglichen hier sieht man
die wifi networks hier test test wlan hat mir jetzt zum beispiel wenn ich jetzt test
wlan ausschalten will drücke ich auf disable zack dann ist test wlan disabled ja aber handy
app ist mega sack bei unify ja das geht aber schön ist es nicht hier hast du halt die
möglichkeit alles drüber einzustellen bei unify brauchst du immer ein controller so
und das feature was ich meine befindet sich hier ich muss euch mal planten aber oder
leute soll ich hell machen oder dunkel ich finde das web interface von denen hat ein
paar bugs wenn es dunkel ist es ich glaube wir lassen es lieber dark mode aber ich mach
ein bisschen größer so und hier gibt es hier gibt es das feature guck mal dynamic dynamic
psk achso ich muss ich muss ja erst mal im wlan das überhaupt enable also geben wir
mal geben wir mal ins geben wir mal ins wlan wifi networks test wlan edit und schalten
das ganze mal ein 0 it dpsk enable dpsk so standardmäßig benutzt er eine 62 zeichenlange
62 zeichenlanges password das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig zum eintippen aber
man kann es auch man kann es auch mit qr codes machen das funktioniert auch
haben die kein wpa 3 support keine ahnung mit der neuesten firme vielleicht keine ahnung
wir müssen auch noch ein firme update machen so also wir schalten das ganze wir schalten
das ganze jetzt ein enable dpsk 42 character passphrase so limit dpsk 1 pro device ok should
expire unlimited ok fertig mehr muss man nicht machen und jetzt kann man hier in die settings
gehen und sagen dpsk und hier kann man jetzt was anlegen jetzt kann ich zum beispiel sagen
man sieht jetzt jetzt zeige ich euch warum ich jetzt das erst machen will weil es gibt
ein neues feature mit der aller neuesten firme deswegen will ich das jetzt machen also das
ist noch eine alte firme da sieht das folgendermaßen aus also ich kann mich jetzt in das wlan wenn
es eingeschaltet wäre ich kann mich jetzt in das wlan verbinden wenn ich das master
password kenne wie gehabt also wenn ich wenn ich dieses password ich zeige es euch jetzt
nicht ja aber wenn ich dieses password hier kenne kann ich mich ganz normal verbinden
wie bei jedem anderen access point auch aber ich kann halt zusätzlich für geräte wo ich
das als sinnvoll erachte und ich würde es wahrscheinlich für jedes jedes gerät machen
kann ich hier passwörter anlegen für dieses wlan pro gerät unleashed kostet nix ich kann
jetzt zum beispiel sagen hier ich will fünf fünf geräte generieren generate alles gut
gut das alt ui ist komisch so und jetzt sieht man das hier jetzt hat er den user angelegt
jetzt hat er die mac adresse noch nicht gesetzt die mac adresse wird gelockt beim ersten mal
wo sich das gerät anmeldet also das funktioniert folgendermaßen ich kann jetzt ich ich gehe
jetzt hier hin und sag ach mein gott wie alt ist denn die firma die da drauf ist mann du
kann sich noch nicht mal qr codes hierfür anzeigen lull mittlerweile kannst du dir qr
codes hierfür anzeigen lassen easy die firma ist die ist uralt hier drauf das muss man
gleich mal gleich mal abdecken das liegt noch nicht am dark seam die ist uralt normalerweise
kannst du den qr code dafür anzeigen lassen zum einscannen könnt ihr dann einscannen
bei euch so und wenn ich wenn zum ersten mal ein user eingelog sich einloggt von seinem
gerät also er geht in die wlan settings gibt gibt user muss er nicht eingeben gibt dieses
password was hier generiert wurde ein für diese ssid dann wird hier eine mac adresse
eingetragen und danach gilt es auch nur noch für diese eine mac adresse und wenn ich das
dann lösche also mal angenommen ich würde jetzt hier einen esp 32 registrieren und werfe
den weg dann gehe ich einfach in sagt die liet sagt man als das gerät weg so man sieht
jetzt schon ein paar doofe sachen in der alten firma version war es nur möglich user hier
so komisch anzulegen also nichts nicht sprechen nicht sagen und auch so ein random password
und sowas alles ziemlich kacke es gab die möglichkeit über eine csv datei zumindest
den den usernamen das mit passphrase stimmt nicht die passphrase ist nicht setzbar die
passphrase ist nur auslesbar außer in der neuen version der neuen version geht das also
man kann den usernamen angeben man kann und das war es eigentlich man kann den mac und
den usernamen angeben und das wlan dann kann man das hochladen aber als csv mann ich mach
doch keine cht doch keine csv datei um es hier hoch zu laden für einen neuen user das
ist eklig passphrase ist read only was man nicht machen kann und was ein feature war was
total oft angefragt wurde ist warum kann man da nicht ein gerät anlegen hier in der oberfläche
und selbst ein password für vergeben bisher war man darauf angewiesen das unleashed das
password für ein generiert das ist nicht so schlimm weil man kann in den qr code scan
aber es ist doof und seit der allerneuesten version also wie gesagt in alten firma version
ist das read only dieses passphrase das kann ich das kann ich nicht nicht setzen hier drüber
so bis auf die allerneueste firma version die allerneueste firma version die hat die
möglichkeit also unleashed 200.13 release notes release notes die allerneueste
ich mach mal kurz ein neues password mann
ich accepte alles was war das für big connect scheiße das ist carlos matos from new york
city new york so thank you for registration ok es ist noch nicht da ich hoffe die haben
das nicht geblockt man das wird mich jetzt mal mega abfangen darf ich das runterladen
vielleicht auch so schon
rougos dear keckel please confirm your email by clicking on the link below
er
nice
kann man sich hier irgendwo einfach da da ist er da ist er der rougos link
ok also jetzt kann man sich einloggen und jetzt zeige ich euch mal ein neues feature weshalb
ich die neue firmware haben will und deswegen auch im web interface ein bisschen rumwursten
will new features das feature worauf ich scharf bin ist das hier dpsk enhancements und zwar
das hier allowing administrators to set own dpsk das heißt ich kann jetzt einen user mit
eigenem namen anlegen zum beispiel max sein iphone und kann ein eigenes password dafür
vergeben nicht mehr so ein random unaussprechliches password ich kann mir quasi ein eigenes password
verfahren benutzen ja battery horse stable oder wie heißt das aus diesem xkc comic battery
horse stable so zumindest kann ich eigenen dpsk anlegen und dann für meine geräte verwenden
hat das auch hat das teil auch eine api keine offizielle du kannst dich per ssh verbinden
und da manche sachen auslesen oder oder du kannst es so machen wie ich was ich was wir
auch schon mal im stream gemacht haben du kannst die inoffizielle api benutzen die sie in ihrem
eigenen web interface benutzen oder so wie wir es heute machen wir machen es heute ein
bisschen anders heute moden wir das web interface wofür steht dpsk dynamic pre-shared key also
psk pre-shared key ist ja das was jeder daheim bei seinem wlan macht keiner benutzt wpa enterprise
daheim mit radioserver und geschiss pre-shared key ist ein anderes wort für password wlan
password der psk ist ein wlan password was du eintippen musst wenn du dich zu deinem
wlan verbinden willst das ist der das ist der pre-shared key und ein dpsk ist quasi
ein dynamisches wlan password das heißt du kannst für unterschiedliche geräte unterschiedliche
wlan password haben allerdings für das gleiche wlan so es gibt noch ein paar andere nützliche
nützliche funktionen man kann sich zum man kann zum beispiel den usernamen jetzt nachträglich
ändern man kann beispielsweise direkt und das ist auch ein cooles feature was viele andere
hersteller nicht haben man kann zum beispiel auch direkt anhand des dpsk mit was der das
gerät sich einlog das gerät in das passende wlan packen was auch sehr cool ist wenn man
das wenn man das benutzt ja also man könnte man könnte dann zum beispiel sagen ok man
hat ein gäste wlan allerdings in diesem gäste wlan gibt es vielleicht sowas wie
meine meine bekannte und bekannte von den kindern oder sowas die kriegen unterschiedliche
wlan dass die kinder nicht auf irgendwelche pilserber zugreifen können oder so kannst
du dann unterschiedliche sachen einstellen also man könnte man könnte anhand des pre-shared
key dann auch die geräte in unterschiedliche wlan automatisch zuordnen das ist eine coole
das wirklich weiß benutze ich bei mir daheim nicht deshalb ist aber cool so dass also dieses
feature ist das worauf ich eigentlich scharf bin hast du den cc na wenn ja ja ich habe
tatsächlich den cc na also mittlerweile habe ich den nicht mehr habe ich habe den z ich
habe das ich habe das 2008 oder so habe ich meinen cc na kram gemacht tips habe ich nicht
wir hatten damals eine schulung wo so zwei leute am start waren die haben den rack mit
gebracht dann hat man dann im rack zeug aufgebaut zusammengestöpselt ich würde muss ehrlich
sagen so schwierig war der cc na im nachhinein jetzt wenn ich mich da so zurück erinnere
nicht man lernt recht viel netzwerkunden lang man lernt halt unglaublich viel cisco spezifische
bezeichnung die technologien ist ja dass das das meiste haben alle aber cisco hat so eigenheiten
von der benahmung her zum beispiel zum beispiel ist es jetzt ein port port aggregation oder
ist es ein port channel oder oder oder den bonding interface oder so ja da streiten sich
die netzwerk hersteller so ein bisschen mal heißt so mal heißt so mal ist es was ganz
anderes ich glaube ich glaube bei cisco heißt es port channel oder so den bonding interface
das nennt jeder ein bisschen anders meine augen mann so und das ist das ist der grund
warum ich warum ich die neue firme haben will wir haben vor einer ganzen weile im
stream mal ein web interface kann kein web interface ein command line tool gebaut für
mein exes point zeige euch mal kurz hier ja wir haben wir haben vor einer ganzen weile
mal kommando zeilen klein gebaut für die für die exes points allerdings mit den limitierungen
die die firme damals halt noch hatte und die neue firme ist halt richtig nice dass man
jetzt zum ersten mal eigene passwörter setzen kann mega poc so das heißt wir gehen jetzt
mal hier auf eher 610 und laden uns mal die neueste firme runter wer jetzt denkt einfach
über das ding hier abzug abzug der liegt falsch man kann zwar irgendwie drei jahre
später man hat zwar hier eine firme selection die geht aber plus bis 207 punkt zehn warum
ich weiß es nicht sie geht zumindest nicht bis 213 vielleicht muss man auch zwischen
ab crane das ist in 510 das steht 610 hinten drauf oh nee 510 ich habe mich verguckt ich
habe ich hätte wetten können das ist ein 610 ok na gut soll mir auch recht sein der
funktioniert genauso ich weiß wir machen jetzt auch local upgrade ich hätte wetten
können 610 ok na gut ich mein soll mir auch recht sein geht genauso
testet doch mal die neueste firme aus der liste den ich zeitschieß mit an nichts also
vielleicht vielleicht wollen die auch dass man zwischen dass man zwischen upgrades macht
oder so aber wir machen keine zwischen upgrades wir laden uns einfach das neueste firmware
von der webseite und pushen das da rein katschi bus unleashed 213 das brauchen wir genau
download moment moment es ist ja auch keine sekunde ich hätte fast das falsche hochgeladen
da ist es ihr seht die firme ist relativ neu die ist von november 2022 510
man muss ihn zur gute halten die schreiben tatsächlich ganz brauchbare patch notes was
wollen die hier oben nö gehst du weg ok local upgrades browse downloads alter das sieht ja
mal richtig fancy aus mein mein mein picker mein file picker dialog warum sieht der so
fancy aus sah das letzte mal auch schon so cool aus
alles klar nice die sieht hat ja was sieht er richtig cool aus so upgrade
ist das ein nautilus ne das war das war der firefox firefox die file picker als als ich
hab noch nicht mal nautilus installiert normalerweise habe ich tuner hier am start um immer das
so fancy ausgeschaut hat keine ahnung ok bla bla bla bla bla bla upgrade
master ap will set factory during upgrade process was wollen die mir damit sagen dass
ich das ding resettet oder was da habe ich jetzt aber keinen bock drauf vielleicht ist
das vielleicht ist das versions upgrade vielleicht ist das versions der versionssprung zu hoch
vielleicht müssen wir doch erst das hier machen ja oder wir machen wir machen backup
und dann restoren wir das backup oder kommen wir machen wir machen mal ich sehe schon das
wird heute schwierig mit monen das ist ein r510 komm wir machen mal ein upgrade da drauf
upgrade und dann auf das nächste wahrscheinlich behält er dann die firmen wir machen wir
machen mal ein kleineres das upgrade geht relativ schnell so fünf minuten pro access point
ungefähr hält sich hält sich in grenzen
bei mikrotik geht das schneller aber mikrotik geht aber manchmal was kaputt wobei ihr bestimmt
auch es macht aber wenig sinn so einzelne punkte zwischen den herstellern zu vergleichen
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich geht in 20 euro wahrscheinlich geht in 20 euro tp link von
amazon noch schneller und wahrscheinlich geht ein super krass feature reiches cisco cisco
cross switch braucht länger also man kann immer schwierig das da miteinander zu vergleichen
macht eigentlich wenig sind die drei verses hyperland hyperland ist komplett inkompatibel
mit vms und auch daran sich sehr buggy und warum i3 verses sway weil sway rumbackt und
wayland in der vm ok reboot gib ihm schau mal ping gucken wir das ding wieder da ist
absolut high speed upgrading process wie gesagt so fünf minuten hat es das letzte mal gedauert
ich habe auch abgecranet also meine live access point sind schon auf der neuen firmenversion
deswegen weiß ich auch wie unterschiedlich wie unterschiedlich das aussieht
übrigens die dinger sind meistens schneller fertig als dieser komische balken da was anzeigt
ok er rebootet gerade danach ist er wieder am start ausrufe zeichen heute stimmt überhaupt
nicht übrigens sag ich du bist jetzt motge du hast jetzt auch die rechte wenn du bock
hast ich verpflichte hier kein motge zu arbeiten wenn er nicht will du kannst auch den als
heute kommando editieren jetzt ich kann dir aber nicht sagen wie du das über chat commands
machst ich weiß nur dass es geht es geht über chat commands kannst du den heute heute anzeige
vom vom nightbot ändern ich habe keine ahnung wie das geht das macht der serious max sonst
vielleicht vielleicht weiß es einer der anderen motges ich sehe das sag ich ist schon vorbereitet
so ist er wieder da er ist wieder da
und danach müssen wir noch ein upgrade machen auf die allerneueste firmenversion
aber es heute ich gucke mal kurz den anderen browser fenster wie weiter schon ist ok da
macht noch gar nichts ich habe nichts gesagt ist einfach nur langsam oder blinkt auch noch
oder blinkt aber sehr merkwürdig gerade ich hoffe mal dass das blinken mir sagen soll
er macht gerade firmware updates da ist er easy jetzt hat er auch aufgehört zu blinken
an liege ok und jetzt noch mal ein update jawoll upgrade jetzt darf ich auf 13 ok alles
klar jetzt darf ich auf 13 upgrade
was machst du da erklärt für nicht programmieren wir programmieren nichts ich mache ein firmware
update von meinem access point das hast du vielleicht daheim auch schon mal gemacht und
sei es nur dass du mal ein fritzbox update gemacht hast ich habe ich kann mir ab machen
firmware update auf meinem access point
und danach können wir zum eigentlichen punkt kommen was ich machen will weil ich will nämlich
das web interface ein bisschen anpassen und warum das zeige ich euch gleich wenn das upgrade
fertig ist geht es vielleicht noch langsamer die firmen wird zu laden
kann es kann es noch kann es vielleicht noch ein bisschen also leute mir ist es ein bisschen
zu schnell wie er das lehnt ich hätte gern moin johls noch wieder am start ich hätte
gerne dass er noch langsamer lädt also es ist es ist cringe wenn er vor 22 Uhr fertig
ist johls wie sieht es aus overwatch 2 gespielt mal in letzter zeit
boah das ist aber schon abverklangsam hier mann okay cancel ich habe cancel gedrückt
sonst nix okay kein schimmer was das zeug da macht
soll ich probiere ich probiere ich probiere ich probiere noch mal ab upload ob es jetzt
schneller geht wenn nicht wenn nicht mache ich local upgrade
das ist sehr komisch gewesen
gerade
die firmware ich kann euch sagen in was die firmware programmiert ist also das web interface
das web interface ist react das back end ist das ist eine ledung basierte firmware ich
habe die firmware schon mal runter geladen und anpackt ist
das back end könnte sogar pap sein react frontend pap back end
das ist jsp javascript server pages oder sowas ne ne es ist kein java ich glaube es ist pap
frag mich nicht warum es jsp ist ich bin mir relativ sicher dass dass ich gesehen habe
dass es pap ist ich habe ich habe nämlich die ich habe nämlich die firmware mal runter
geladen und extracted es kann aber auch sein dass ich jetzt dass ich es durcheinander bringe
ne anscheinend ist es doch nicht pap mach keinen plan
keine ahnung ich mein wir könnten mal wir könnten nachgucken während der upgrade hat
ok downloads wir haben noch die firmware hier unten mkdir tackle r510 hallo ah ich bin blöd
bl7 extract
github extract es gibt irgendjemand hat es schon extract dem firmware
boah keine ahnung ich habe die firmware schon mal irgendwann extra hier vor als ich die
dinger neu gekauft habe frag mich nicht mehr wie das ging war das dann zwar das vielleicht
vielleicht vielleicht was es könnte tatsächlich bin walk gewesen sein ja ja squash fs filesystem
und wie benutzt man das jetzt ich glaube es war tatsächlich bin walker wie extra hier
gibt man den krempel jetzt extract ja extracted root fs oder ist nix drinnen null
kann man hier noch zu bieten 7 zip das kann ich bestimmt bestimmt irgendwie mountain keine
ahnung wie 7 zip extract naja yes yes ok keine ahnung was ich hier sehe
mount naja mount gucken ob man das überhaupt mounten kann ne
wie geht das unsquash wie kriege ich das drauf unsquash fs da muss bestimmt squash fs utils
oder sowas hier unsquash ist klar wo ist es
ach da ist es jetzt jetzt ist es extracted ok so jetzt können wir jetzt können wir in
die firme reingucken was da was da drin ist ja web ja web wo liegt das web interface admin
7zip mod ok leute ich hab mich schon mal vertan es ist kein pp es ist irgendein binary shit
oder so was ist was ist denn das für ein komisches zeug man web ap web hätten wir
noch zu bin index html ok das ist das andere web wird es schon sein oder weil die haben
wir quasi das css und das ganze zeug drin die haben keine eigenen webserver die verwenden
irgend so ein embedded webserver scripts was ist das denn für jquery ok lasst mich mal
kurz was checken jquery 3.6 wann wurde das denn hey das ist ja richtig recent alles die
weit ist mein flashvorgang fertig fertig flash champ javascript unleash ist up to date ok
nice ich würde jetzt aber trotzdem noch interessieren in was dieses web interface programmiert
ist was egs xml was ist das für eine ausgeburt des bösen hier xml mit javascript zeugs drinnen
was auch immer haben hier vielleicht index index punkt mod ok dot mod file was ist das
im dot mod file mod format tracker modul ok leute keine ahnung was es ist es ist irgendein
komisches binary format wo html drinnen ist oder sowas in der richtung zumindest also
hat keine ahnung was es ist das habe ich vorhin schon geguckt was ich habe keinen plan was
es ist mod files g fortran das wird damit wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun haben gut wie
dem auch sei leute am-f keckel wobei wir können es ja mal hier liegen lassen vielleicht wollen
wir mal was nachgucken so und jetzt kann ich euch zeigen warum ich die neue firmware benutzen
will wenn man mit der neuen firmware jetzt hier auf dynamic psk geht dann hat man mehr
sachen zur auswahl unter anderem kann ich jetzt auf generate gehen mir das beispielding runterladen
und jetzt kann ich auch eine passphrase setzen die nicht mehr read only ist sondern read
write also sprich ich kann jetzt hier zum beispiel angeben max iphone mac adresse lasse ich leer
vlan lasse ich leer und passphrase wird keckel omega 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0 blub so beste passphrase
dann speicher ich das gehe auf brows das ist das ist ein richtig eklicher weg ja ich zeig
es euch nur mal wieder hochladen er erkennt ein profil da drinnen dann gehe ich auf generate
success da mache ich das zu und ihr seht jetzt habe ich einen neuen user geedet max iphone
mit dieser passphrase noch keine mac adresse eingetragen das heißt sobald ich mich das
erste mal mit einem gerät verbinde dann wird das fest gelockt auf diese geräte auf diese
geräte merkt und der rest bleibt so easy und wenn ich wieder weg haben will kann ich auch
sagen die lied ist wieder weg so das geht erst seit der allerneuesten firmware version und
das ist ein mega nice feature dass man jetzt custom user custom user kamer schlänger aber
custom passwörter benutzen kann deswegen habe ich mir folgendes überlegt ich habe
euch ja gerade gezeigt wie man das hier macht ja also noch mal dass ihr seht jetzt also
obacht dass ihr seht wie wie eklig das ist wenn ich einen user anlegen will wie geht
das ab übergreifend ein access point ist der master und er macht das alles und dann
sügt er das auf die anderen rüber also quasi wie ein controller nur dass der access point
ist und nebenbei noch controller macht also man muss auf generate gehen sich das sample
profil runterladen das sample profil editieren in wishlist studio code dann das wieder hoch
laden mit dem editierten user und dann auf generate drücken was passiert bei rotieren
der mac adresse die mac adresse rotiert nicht so funktioniert das nicht die mac adresse
rotiert nur wenn der access point sich ändert beziehungsweise wenn sich das netzwerk ändert
oder access point ändert also das ist eine random meiste mac adresse pro ssid kann man
so grob sagen das ist beim iphone auch so das iphone random meiste die mac adresse nicht
jedes mal neu nein leute so funktioniert das nicht das iphone generiert quasi grob gesagt
pro ssid einmal eine neue mac und die bleibt dann gleich sonst würden ja dhcp reservierung
alles mögliche gar nicht funktionen ja du kannst sicherlich in deinem iphone selbst
anklicken ich möchte eine neue mac adresse haben aber standardmäßig gibt es eine mac
adresse pro netzwerk die random meiste ich nicht alle fünf minuten oder nach neustart
oder so sonst würde ja total vieles nicht funktionieren das ist ja nur gedacht dass
ihr nicht getrackt werden könntet über wlan hinweg und so was allerdings was macht man
bei rotierender mac adresse ist ja eine legitime frage da macht man gar nichts da muss man
sich neu anmelden wenn es wenn wenn das einmalig gelockt ist auf ein gerät mit dem password
dann kann sich nur noch dieses gerät anmelden mit dem password und wenn du das änderst
obwohl es das gleiche gerät ist sieht es aus wie neues gerät es wird nicht funktionieren
das kannst du aber umgehen du kannst bei denen also wenn man das wirklich wenn man das möchte
ja die haben ja schon an vieles gedacht du kannst zum beispiel in die netzwerk settings
gehen und dann sagst du dass du pro dps cast beispielsweise fünf geräte erlauben willst
also vier vier ist das maximal ja also kannst du quasi sagen ok der typ darf sich mit seinem
user mit seinem smartphone und seinem tablet anmelden und es ist der gleiche user das geht
auch es ist wirklich super durchdacht was sie da gebaut haben ich kann mich da nicht
beschweren ist schon cool gemacht
die option darunter ja das ist jetzt übrigens auch neu dedicated master wenn man irgendwie
riesig große installationen betreibt mit irgendwie hunderten access points und tausenden
clients da kann man mittlerweile auch einen leistungs starken access point zu einem dedicated
master machen was da quasi so eine art controller ist
moment was was ist da unten drunter
ach so ja du hast recht dann weiß ich gar nicht was was das hier eigentlich für eine
option ist limit dps card ach so dass ich mehrere dps cards für user generieren kann
und hier kann ich quasi den dps card zwischen mehreren devices scheren ok ja das könnte
ich dann hier also hier kann ich zum beispiel sagen dass ein user mehrere dps cards haben
kann und ein dps card kann geschert werden auch zwischen mehreren devices ok ok ja so
und was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe ist folgendes man darf das nicht auf user basis denken man
muss das finde ich eher auf geräte basis denken und einfach jedem gerät einen eigenen dps
card geben man hat ja genug also der r710 unterstützt glaube ich 2048 dps cards und
2048 geräte hast du im heimbereich eigentlich weniger im wlan
ich glaube sogar der kleine 510 unterstützt 512 geräte oder so
also folgendes was ich mir gedacht habe was man machen könnte ich habe euch jetzt ja
gezeigt also es relativ umständlich hier user zu generieren was ich mir jetzt gedacht
habe was man machen könnte natürlich ist das nicht so einfach jetzt mal nebenbei in
die firmware eingebaut oder so also das werden wir auch nicht machen also ich mache keine
custom firmware irgendwie für für dieses point also falls es gehen sollte aber wir
können ja trotzdem die seite die das web interface moden und zwar hätte ich nicht
nur gerne diesen generate knopf sondern wisst ihr was sie wisst ihr was ich gerne hätte
ich hätte hier einen knopf dps k und wenn ich auf diesen knopf drücke dann geht quasi
ein dialog auf ähnlich zu diesem und da gebe ich ein username password und wähle das wlan
aus und drücke auf ok und dann fügt er das ein jetzt ist natürlich die große preisfrage
wie moden wir das web interface am besten und dazu verwenden wir sowas wie temper monkey
also gibt es ja mehrere möglichkeiten es gibt grease monkey das ist das erste es gibt
temper monkey das ist so der fork davon und es gibt einen neuen einen neuen fork der nennt
sich violent monkey das ist quasi die neueste war herrnte davon proxy brauchen wir nicht
proxy würde vielleicht auch gehen das ist eine browser extension meine auge das ist
eine browser extension add und mit der browser extension kann man bestehende seiten verändern
habe ich noch nicht gemacht keine ahnung ich habe mir nur gestern ein tutorial dazu angeguckt
und mit dieser extension probieren wir jetzt mal ob ich es schaffe hier einen button hinzu
zufügen wenn ich auf den button klicke geht ein menü auf da trage ich user und password
ein er edit das refresh das hier unten drin und es funktioniert das wird kompliziert
wahrscheinlich okay probier das mal aus wie gesagt kein kein plasten davon ein script
was haben da add create new script das klingt schon mal ganz gut wir müssen mal kurz wir
müssen mal kurz in die docs guide hat er hat er da sehen hier also create a new script
das haben wir gemacht ja user was blabla modern sonntags ja ist ja gut ich will kein npm installieren
und da eine komplette webapp draus machen mann übertreibt es halt mal ich will fünf zeilen
java script hinzufügen kennt jemand von euch ein cooles minimales framework für sowas also
jetzt kein view oder sonst was sondern irgendein bisschen was wie jquery so ein bisschen was
wie jquery das was es einfach angenehmer macht vielleicht die idee ist gar nicht so
schlecht wir machen wir machen vanilla van vanilla js ok also wir legen mal ein neues
script script ach guck mal da merkt sich auch hier gleich die seite ok wir testen mal was
console log ach ja ja aber mal so dass man sich ein wenig editieren kann ach ja ja ok
wird schon mal ausgeführt auf der seite und jetzt und jetzt kommt natürlich das komplizierte
die kriege ich da einen button rein jetzt bräuchte mir den aus kennen fuchs der hat
bei sowas ja immer plant l pine js das klingt tatsächlich ganz nice ich werde das framework
list machen ja das sieht schon besser aus das sieht schon das sieht schon ganz angenehm
aus ok also ich will ich will den button button dahin machen wie kriege ich da den button
hin erst mal kurz gucken inspect ok button toolbar group das klingt doch eigentlich
ganz ganz sinnvoll ok ok leute ich war ich war wir machen wir hier moment copy css selektor
alles klar ok document query selektor massive java javascript skills javascript hello paste
java hallo ah mist ich kann nur ich habe mein klipp hat immer noch ausgeschaltet lull copy
selektor hallo man ich will copy paste man allow pasting muss ich machen jetzt
wir haben kein jquery am start so es ist jetzt das richtige ja toolbar button nee
wie ist das ding drum herum toolbar group ok tool toolbar group nice nice das ist das
nee das das will ich da will ich was da will ich was anhängen echt moment die haben jquery
was wie wirklich oder doch nee mach man das so warte es ist 50 jahre her wo ich jquery
verwendet habe wie kann ich denn überhaupt testen ob es check ob es jquery gibt die gibt
es da ist jquery included ok leute 2023 web development auf geht's jquery in the house
ja jquery und und wie benutzt man das jetzt so einfach ok jquery dollar hat nicht funktioniert
guck dollar funktioniert nicht nur jquery funktioniert ich meine es ist javascript
man kann bestimmt dollar gleich jquery machen oder so und jetzt geht auch dollar aber das
ist wahrscheinlich das ist wahrscheinlich brocken ob was geht body ja jetzt jetzt geht
das jetzt geht das ich will reload immer nee das geht nicht wir bleiben wir bleiben
bei jquery ok ich meine wir können ja j zu jquery aliasten oder so was auch immer was
auch immer das war ok also leute jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen ein bisschen was gucken
als services dynamic psk da wollen wir hin wir wollen nach nav bar from nav bar left
exzellent also jquery da ist es nee muss ja muss ich punkte davor machen gell punkt
punkt punkt nee wie macht man das in jquery so sub select alle hier ist es schon ne das
jetzt jetzt ist aber zu viel also normalerweise würde ich jetzt machen ohne lehrzeichen also
quasi also quasi so so hey das funktioniert also normalerweise hätte ich jetzt gesagt
document query selektor mal das ganze ohne jquery gemacht so punkt punkt punkt ok dann
gehts auch nicht muss man das muss man das so machen kein flassen schimmer alter javascript
ok nice sehr schön also das das das funktioniert ok toolbar so toolbar ist selected kopier
ich kopier ich mir schon mal rein also toolbar ist selected so und jetzt will ich sind ich
schreibe mal kurz hier in den editor was ich vorhabe ich bin mir nicht wirklich so sicher
ob das funktioniert also jquery wir können das wir können das mal skopen dass es nicht
so dass es nicht so kaputt geht Leute geht das in javascript kann ich kann wir machen
einfach function main so so war das jetzt weil jetzt kann ich hier drinnen zum beispiel
auch sagen dass da ist jquery so und dann dann dann mache ich auch nichts kaputt falls
das so möglich ist leute ich bin komplett planlos was sind diese java geschichten angeht
also jetzt schauen wir mal console log wir machen es mal hier unten kurz in der konsole
was ich machen will so also hier ist das ele per scope definieren ja also das hat so was
in der richtung so was ne ja genau genau so also wir probieren das mal hier unten so
hier jquery da kommt jetzt was raus jetzt kann ich glaube ich sagen append append kann
man da jetzt direkt einen diff rein machen wahrscheinlich nicht oder oder doch ok js
append element konst die leute sind element append
das will ich machen genau create element diff das will ich machen ok ok ok ich teste das
mal kurz hier create element ne das funktioniert so nicht also das ist ja richtig abartig hier
unten in der command line zu machen ok let diff und jetzt will ich sowas machen wie diff
antwortet vanilla javascript so also jetzt wirds jetzt wirds advanced ok ich seh da noch
ein weiteres problem leute und zwar dass dieses ding nicht geladen ist wenn ich die seite
zum ersten mal aufmache ich seh schon es ist keine so gute idee gewesen das wird wieder
viel größere abfacke und komplizierter als ich mir das ganze vorgestellt habe ok wir
bauen es jetzt mal so als als würde es funktionieren ok diff kann man da irgendwie visual studio
für verwenden ach was ist das use another editor how to edit scripts with your favorite
editor aha excellent first copy the script to your favorite editor and save it to a file
ja auf die idee bin ich auch schon gekommen das dann hin und her zu kopieren ja moment
was install a local script ach die serven das lokal die serven die seite lokal ok das
machen wir das machen wir weil easy way won't work for firefox users nice gut dass wir firefox
verwenden hardway start a local htp server and open the local script with the urlag was
hardway start a local htp server and open the local script with the urlag
wie jetzt ich mein wir können wir können es wir können es ja ausprobieren so repos
das ding heißt eindeutig dps card champ touch ok das muss ja nicht mein script heißen das
heißt hier irgendwie dps car script user punkt js sondern kopieren wir mal hier einfach nur
dass ich will mal gucken wie das überhaupt funktioniert was die sich da vorstellen weil
ich will das lieber in visual studio code edit seriously als hier drinnen der editor hier
fack mich jetzt schon ab wenn ich das wenn ich das sehe wobei wir das ja so machen müssen
ok uni und und jetzt python 8 8.000 so serving alles klar das heißt wenn ich jetzt auf local
host port 8.000 gehe und das kript auf wie auch immer der das jetzt erkannt hat confirm
reinstallation ok ich konfirme die reinstallation und er ist undy feind ok das heißt ich kann
das hier jetzt zumachen sehe ich das jetzt richtig ich kann das hier jetzt zumachen und
ich kann jetzt visual studio code aufmachen und hier drinnen editieren hat das auto reload
natürlich nett das wäre ja auch so einfach aber das hat nicht funktioniert wie reloadet
das jetzt das check ich net das ist das mir zu entwarnet habe keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
richtig seit habe ich das jetzt zugemacht habe das ich habe das hier gespeichert also
hier hat das ja gescheckt karl localhost 8.000 dps kript user.js ja hier das hier das kapiert
ich habe den haken vergessen ok und jetzt
tut sich jetzt aber nichts und hier tut sich hier tut sich gar nichts ok ich bin ich bin
für die bedienung schon mal zu blöd ok oder muss ich jetzt noch mal auf confirm drücken
ah ok ok das hat so eine art so eine art fast fast life reload ah ja ok ok schon mal viel
besser ok nice sehr schön sehr schön ok jetzt funktioniert das jetzt kann man nämlich
visual studio code benutzen wir müssen aber vorher noch mal ganz ganz furchtbar essentiell
settings und pick preferences user settings will ich haben so ich will font umstellen
ich finde font font family hack nicht lenz hack font size 16 ah 20 ah bisschen groß
18 dankeschön für den sub striker striker ja so ist gut wir machen komm wir machen
zwar ein bisschen kleiner weil das mal ein bisschen was das mal ein bisschen was erkennt
und wie macht man dieses sidebar remove sidebar ich habe ich habe die linux vm hier neu installiert
ich glaube ich habe visual studio code hier drin noch gar nicht benutzt toggle minimap
ja so ist nice ein bisschen kleiner so jetzt jetzt passt so ist eigentlich ganz gut ok
hast du den extra werbeblock bei twitch gebucht was für ein ding ne du meinst du diese twitch
stinger die man im profil buchen kann wo es dann irgendwie 2,50 Euro gibt ne die gucke
ich mir noch nicht mal an die gucke ich mir noch nicht mal an joshi party ich sehe ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob dir klar ist was wir eigentlich gerade machen ich will nicht einfach
in den debugger attachen ich will dass die extension mein lo mein über ein htp lokal
gesurftes user script fall neulädt und das geht nur so so ok jetzt können wir weitermachen
mit dem button so das war überlegen und fragt bitte nicht warum jquery leute jquery weil
es vor installiert ist nicht weil ich da scharf drauf bin so diff ok wie funktioniert das
jetzt wie funktioniert das jetzt also das hier ist quasi die toolbar und ich will jetzt
in der toolbar append ne warum erkennt er das nicht ah weil visual studio keine ahnung
hat dass das hier jquery ist ok leute scheiß auf jquery wir machen das einfach richtig
document query selektor toolbar left brauchen wir wahrscheinlich gibt es eine grobe auflösung
ja du kannst entweder meine dot files dir angucken da guck die kannst du dir angucken
auf github wieso ein 1500 euro dollar access point weil er features hat die ich haben will
kannst dir meine dot files angucken oder du kannst dir immer schief den stream angucken
wo wir einiges eingerichtet haben so toolbar und jetzt lädt er das alles richtig ok nice
so machen wir das weg also query selektor toolbar jetzt können wir noch gerade mal gucken
console log jetzt haben wir ordentlich autocomplete toolbar jetzt können wir mal gucken ob er
das erkennt die toolbar ist null die toolbar ist null weil logisch logisch weil der shit
noch nicht geladen ist das heißt wir müssen jetzt irgendwie observe die webseite auf changes
und wenn das in view kommt ja ich habe im einsatz ich glaube so spricht man das aus
schaess moa schaess moa baguette heim das jetzt immer neu ist ob serve atml changes detect
changes in dom mutation observer observe alles klar wird schon werden dankeschön für den
sub du hast das legit die tage erst gemacht nice da kucke ich mir das einfach bei dir
ab was ist das hier für ein projekt pietz mit reaction extension was macht man damit
egal higher q shit so callback fang mutation observer mutation observer ob so hier hier
machst du das ger konst observer new mutation ob server ich glaube ich glaube dir einfach
dass das funktioniert ich glaube dir einfach mal so dass das so funktioniert wir testen
das jetzt also nu das müssen wir ja da können wir uns den graben mit main eigentlich auch
sparen ok ob server ob serve callback callback ok ich muss mal kurz gucken wie die das wie
die das hier bei mozilla machen ja konst kon das ist im prinzip das gleiche was du
auch machst ger ist im prinzip genauer gleiche graben nur dass nur dass die hier irgendwie
ein bisschen die backzeug anzeigen so das heißt wenn ich das jetzt reload sollte ich
ein schaltnot has been added or removed ok wenn ich jetzt hier rum klicke sollte ich
eine benachrichtigung kriegen für jeden für alles was eingefügt wird ja services tatsächlich
schaltnot has been added das funktioniert so also attributes jucken mich null
mutation boah das habe ich noch nie gemacht schon mal ok da sieht man jetzt was eingefügt
wird in die seite wenn man das anklickt also dann klicken wir mal das an wo man hin wollen
die an dein dynamic key ja guck mal jetzt sieht man dass dieser krempel hier eingefügt wird in
der seite boah the fuck ok also dann machen wir das einfach mal einfach mal so wir machen
einen callback und if einfach mal so wenn er das gefunden hat if toolbar und gleich null
ob das geht in javascript so schon wieder nicht aber probieren wir aus also wenn er die toolbar
gefunden hat dann machen wir einen break und führen eine weitere funktion aus nämlich ja
die können wir tatsächlich main ist ein bisschen doof main da drüber aufzurufen aber ok wenn
wir ja für add button heißt das einfach add button ok so add button auf folgendes element
ok klappt es jetzt so wir sollten jetzt gleich eine ausgabe bekommen sollte ich hier auf dps k
klicken hey funst barprop was barprop was also es funktioniert aber es macht nicht das was ich
was ich mir vorgestellt habe aber mein parameter ist nicht barprop ah moment mit warum gibt er
überhaupt was aus ich gebe das falsche auslul wenn toolbar undefined ist jetzt ist da nicht
null ist andefined ok andefined ist ja nicht nur wir sind ja javascript da darf man das darf man
das nicht alles so über einen cam scheren funst funst ja nice der zeigt der zeigt das nur an
das ist das ist gut wir müssen noch mal kurz gucken ob das ding nicht vielleicht noch ein
paar mehr sachen hat worauf wir drauf filtern können breiter machen toolbar toolbar auto
ach hier guck mal auto dps k table ds das klingt schon mal sehr sinnvoll danach zu
filtern also so dann sollte das nämlich nur auf diese eine matchen auf geht's console
also ich drücke immer ins falsche dps k funst ok warum er das genau zweimal anzeigt verstehe
ich nicht so genau aber ok mal gucken so und jetzt das ist javascript du kannst einfach
toolbar achja geht das if if not nee if if toolbar jetzt füge jetzt fügen wir mal ein
button ein jetzt fügen wir mal ein button ein boah das wird ja noch richtig eklig man wenn ich
wenn ich mir schon so ein abbreche hier einen button einzufügen wie ist es dann erst mit
einem overlay und einem form input das wird ja wieder eine sache von zwei tagen dass das
funktioniert weil ok ok also zumindest in button kriegen wir heute auf jeden fall gebacken man so
add button soll wir haben jetzt hier in den diff in dem diff in den ok wir gucken uns jetzt einfach
mal wie dieser button hier aufgebaut ist falls du es übersehen hast insert ist doch alles brauche
ich doch gar nicht hier button den wollen wir haben copy outer html ja das wird zweimal aufgerufen
wahrscheinlich weil sich mehrere sachen da oben ändert insert des sind oder wie man das ausspricht
element html ok das das muss ich gleich das muss ich gleich ausprobieren das ist zu zu
big big brain gerade so erstmal copy also html hier ist der button react text geht nicht der
nf nicht rum nicht react text add dps k heißt es jetzt so button diff inner html gleich da
machen wir mal ein template element wobei brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht wir machen hier woops
jetzt jetzt so jetzt haben wir hier den den das diff und jetzt sagen wir hier element append
omg typ type annotations leute monkaS wie geht das in java script kann ich dom element oder so
element oh man fack wie macht man type annotations der muss doch wissen achso so element was für
ein was für ein typ ist das hier element nee das ist das ist falsch das ist falsch einfach so
nee ich habe keine ahnung wie man type annotations macht
nee es ist any
kann kann javascript nicht jetzt schon type annotations irgendwie
ich weiß dass es geht aber ich will autocomplete
das ist ja das ist ja man javascript das ist so anstrengend also in dieser art und
weiß ist es anstrengend js dogs ok wie macht man das hier da drüber
js dog type annotation
js type sollte das nicht mittlerweile type annotations können
das ist doch nicht euer ernst oder
ok nee dann nicht vielleicht vielleicht ist visual studio aber so schlau und wenn ich
jetzt sage append dann checkt es dass es ein element ist nee fack macht es nicht ok dann
diff
funktioniert es jetzt so bekomme ich jetzt ok leute wer meint dass ich jetzt ein button
bekomme an der stelle ich habe da meine zweifel ehrlich gesagt services dynamic dps koh die
seite ist kaputt leute ich habe ich habe die seite ich habe die seite geschrottet warum
was ist denn da dran jetzt so so schlimm
was ist was ist da dran jetzt so schlimm
ich meine ist doch nix ist doch nix wildes dabei
observer finished
ah der observer der addenden button und es triggert wieder den observer
ich glaube ok das kann natürlich sein dann müsst ihr sagen diff id ich kann den observer
nicht stoppen ich kann den observer nicht stoppen weil ich will ja ein bisschen drin
rumklicken können es kann sein dass ich rein und raus gehe aus aus der seite das ding kriegt
jetzt eine id das kriegt jetzt eine id dps custom dpsk button immer ich den kram nennen
soll und jetzt gucken wir einfach hier let button document query selector
muss die musik neu starten weil die ist gleich vorbei es sei denn ihr wollt mit shopkeeper
hören
wir machen es wir machen es ohne voice zeug
query selector wie habe ich den genannt custom ne custom dpsk button und und not not a button
hoffe das klappt jetzt was ich hier gebaut habe
oh unleashed dashboard
services bam da isser da isser
button am start einfach einfach button am start
einfach neuer button der button ist allerdings nicht an der richtigen stelle
warum nicht
weil wahrscheinlich irgendwas fehlt hier diff toolbar group fehlt
kann das so add toolbar group admin services dpsk alter perfekt
pif header button besser gehts ja kaum noch so und das muss jetzt nicht append gibt es
auch so was wie prepend dass es am anfang hinkommt massive button ja richtig massive
massive button
ok nice nice wir haben es geschafft button einzubauen mensch poggers poggers
wahnsinn wir machen das mal ein bisschen kleiner dass ich was sehe wir haben ein button ultra
krasser shit der macht noch nix aber wir haben den button darf man nicht unterschätzen oder
überschätzen wie poggers button haben wir den nennen wir nicht dpsk sondern add poggers
wir haben zwanzig minuten oder so gebraucht für den button muss man sich mal vorstellen
aber es ist zumindest halbwegs lesbar ich mein man versteht irgendwie noch so halbwegs
was passiert ok weiter jetzt muss der button natürlich
beim klicken auch was machen also moment moment moment moment wobei eigentlich eigentlich
können wir es so lassen irgendjemand hat ja gerade das gepostet insert adjacent wie spricht
man das aus adjacent adjacent adjacent da ist ja nie drauf gekommen das weiß ich morgen
schon nicht mehr dass man das adjacent ausspricht ok was kann man hier machen insert adjacent
ok da kann man direkt da könnte ich quasi dann sowas sagen wie position null da könnte
ich quasi sowas sagen wie ich machs mal hier tool bar insert so an an stelle null ja ok
das muss ich mal kurz zu mir überlegen also könnte ich dann quasi sagen el so an stelle
null und dann könnte ich hier html quasi reinschreiben also diff mit also so dann
diff glas gleich tool bar all die gleich ist vielleicht vielleicht bisschen bisschen
besser lesbar dann weil keine ahnung ob das wirklich besser lesbar ist diff und dann und
dann den button da rein glas tool bar group ob das ob das auch so funktioniert und dann
den button da rein gucken ob das jetzt auch so funktioniert oder kann man ja kein text
reinschreiben oder wie text steht doch explizit da text ach moment positions so ah moment position
ist selbstverständlich kein index sondern
wie vor beginn wer hat sich das denn wieder ausgedacht wer hat sich das denn wieder ausgedacht
kein plus was der unterschied ist crease monkey ist das ursprüngliche das wird aber kaum
noch weiterentwickelt dann hast du temper manki als fork was irgendwelchen tracking code für
analytics drin hat und hast du weil manki das ist quasi noch mal in fork ohne tracking zeug
drin so wir lassen wir lassen es jetzt einfach so leute wir lassen einfach so jetzt kommt
jetzt jetzt ist die nächste frage heute die nächste frage ist wie kann ich einen klick
händler an den button binden ja mit irgendeinem ordentlich javascript framework und so wüsste
ich wüsste ich also mit zwelt wäre das überhaupt kein ding dann müsste ich auch keinen text
hier schreiben mit html sondern könnte einfach direkt den button drauf zugreifen aber fork
und fork ist eine quasi eine kopie vom source code die sich dann unabhängig weiterentwickelt
ne ne leute ihr habt das problem nicht verstanden ich will auf den button zugreifen und nicht
und nicht auf die toolbar group wobei in dem fall macht es wahrscheinlich keinen unterschied
aber ich habe den button nur als text also müsste ich jetzt quasi noch mal query selektor
machen gib ihm ne id oh ist das abartig alter das ist doch cringe hyper cringe ich könnte
aber auch sagen diff query selektor das geht auch query selektor button aber moment da
gibt es ne das passt doch da ist nur ein button drinne gibt es nur ein button button und jetzt
on click gleich so gell geht das jetzt so war ich das richtig javascript function mäßig
on click ok gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert log heckle bin ich mal gespannt ob das klappt
ich muss das mit dem overlay übrigens anderweitig bauen ich will nicht jedes mal hier unten
immer auf dpsk klicken müssen bam funktioniert heckle da ist es geht einfach es ist einfach
just working forehead just keine fehler programmieren welcher button der hier funktioniert ok wir
haben einfach leute wir haben es geschafft nach 35 minuten ein funktionierenden button
stellt euch das mal vor und nach 45 minuten krasser scheiß man sind wir richtige javascript
hacker man die ultraschnell so was bauen pack den button zum dba ne wir brauchen den button
jetzt nicht mehr der button funktioniert ja ich muss jetzt ein overlay bauen ich muss
jetzt ja ein overlay bauen das overlay kann ich ja kann ich ja anderweitig bauen das muss
ich ja nicht unbedingt durch den button click einfügen lassen ok soweit soweit so gut so
schön jetzt ist die frage wie kriege ich ein overlay hin wie wäre es dem button eine
id zu geben ja könnte ich machen aber wozu also ich kann alles eine id in allem eine
id geben aber ich brauche ja brauche ja nichts mit da brauche ja keine id ok also jetzt
machen wir function function schau ok nice fertig ich weiß nämlich nicht wie ich das
machen soll wir rufen jetzt einfach schauen dialog auf und fertig das bleibt jetzt ok
wie kriege ich ein overlay hin hier guck mal das ist doch ein overlay guck mal das ist
doch quasi schon ein overlay inspect ich kopiere mir das einfach ich ich rippe mir einfach
das overlay hier das das wird jetzt einfach geklaut alter html so allerdings das machen
wir jetzt anders und zwar sagen wir jetzt set timeout weil ich mir sicher bin wenn
ich es direkt anzeige ist es irgendwie kaputt schau dialog nach 500 millisekunden und lock
ich gucke jetzt einfach ob das funktioniert ob das jetzt keckel ausgibt nach dem seiten
neu laden die 123 ausgepasst ok let oh jetzt wirds jetzt wirds eklig dialog gleich so template
string dass es auch funktioniert Leute das ist so broken dass sogar wishell studio code
den kram nicht highlighten will
so broken ist das aber das aber aber es funktioniert falsche string klammern nö nix falsch richtig
so soll ich das nicht vielleicht mal ein bisschen umbrechen dass man noch was erkennt ok pass
mal auf feifett feifett idee feifett idee new einfügen er erkennt dass es er denkt dass
es javascript ist aber falsch das ist html format
poggers poggers ordentlich formatiert spacers das ist zu groß intent using spacers 2 format
so zack bam
da fehlt was oder fehlt da unten noch ein schließendes diff
oder ist die einrückung einfach kaputt
ich hab nen diff hab ich nen diff zu viel ich hab nen diff zu viel oder
clean code hab ich nen diff zu viel ne ne ne hab ich nicht passt schon
so jetzt müssen wir noch ein bisschen was rausschmeißen das alles was wir nicht brauchen
müssen wir mal rausschmeißen so hier das da brauchen wir net
hat ich geb dir header wobei das ist vielleicht nicht so verkehrt titel class titel ok
add dpsk soll der titel sein content form ok weg das war ein bisschen durchweg weg content
noch mal ne form ok das das lassen wir mal extra
plarisch wo ist denn hier noch mal ein select ok diff ok das lassen wir mal extra plarisch
da den anderen shit den schmeiß ich mal alles weg weil da blick ich nicht mehr durch
ich hab das mikrophone vom headset alter was ok weg damit ich darf jetzt nur nicht zu viel
Löschender
Random den Input weg
Weg
weg
Okay, weg, weg, haben wir alles net
Result, Dings, Zeug, weg
Puto, ja, okay, das kann man da lassen. So, also best practice Formatierung
So, und das fügen wir jetzt ein. Okay, okay, wie machen wir das? Das machen wir so wie hier unten, das machen wir so wie hier unten, Dokument, Create, Diff, Create, Diff
Und jetzt
Diff, inner, ich hab, das ist glaube ich echt eine schlechte Idee, aber mir fällt nichts anderes ein. Und jetzt sage ich
Body, nee, Dokument, Body
Joa, keine Ahnung
Append oder so
Diff
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was passiert
Naja, es ist ein Overlay
Hey, das ist zwar nicht so ganz, so ganz richtig angeordnet
Aber ganz so schlimm ist es jetzt auch nicht, oder?
Was ich mache, ich zeig dir, ich zeig dir was ich mache
Ich zeig dir was ich mache, ich will
In dem Web Interface von meinem Access Point
Kann man hier
Geräte hinzufügen und für die ein eigenes WLAN Passwort vergeben
Und es gibt normalerweise nur diesen Generate Button, wo man eine CSV Datei hochladen kann, um neue User anzulegen
Richtig hängen geblieben. So, ich will einen eigenen neuen Button hier hinzufügen
Und beim Klick, du hast es gerade gesehen, beim Klick auf diesen Button soll
ein Popup aufgehen mit einem Formular drin, wo ich einen neuen User hinzufügen kann. Der macht dann vielleicht unter der Haube auch einen CSV
aber
Ich muss nicht jedes Mal von Hand Excel aufmachen oder wie es kommt mit dem CSV
Okay, also das mit dem, das mit dem Overlay funktioniert schon mal, wenn es funktioniert
Wie wäre es mit einem anständigen, das ist ein anständiger Access Point, das ist richtig Pongas Access Point
Der kann nämlich seit diesem Firmware
Update
Zum ersten Mal Custom Keys. Ach, bisher habe ich es über über Kommandozeile gemacht, da war es easy, aber ich will es im Web Interface haben
Mir viel lieber, außerdem kann man da ein bisschen rum basteln
Es gibt nichts Vergleichbares, die haben alle irgendwelche anderen Probleme und Uni-Fi ist das beste, Uni-Fi sagt Feature unterstützen wir gar nicht
Die denken sich so, wer braucht das schon
Jeder andere Hersteller kann es, aber Uni-Fi hat es nicht, obwohl es da schon seit
fünf oder sechs Jahren tausende Feature-Requests gibt, wo man sich die Feature-Requests anbieten kann
Aber Uni-Fi kehrt nicht, die juckt es nicht. Okay, so
Wir haben wir haben eine Form, jetzt ist die Frage, wie können wir das ordentlich alignen, dass es hier nicht so hässlich auf auf halb acht hängt
Also, passt mal auf, jetzt kommen meine
Feature-Requests, die haben wir schon, die haben wir schon, die haben wir schon, die haben wir schon
Also, passt mal auf, jetzt kommen meine Hyper-CSS-Skills zum Tragen
Das war es schon mal nicht
Okay, Margin-Top ist das Problem, ich sehe es schon, ich sehe es schon
So, Wid wollen wir nicht haben, wir wollen
Doch, wollen wir haben, wir wollen Breite, wollen wir 80 von der Bildschirmbreite haben
Der Bildschirmbreite haben
Von der Fensterbreite, okay
Schon besser, schon besser
Ja, damit kann ich leben, wenn das da eingeplendet wird
Jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage, was passiert
Und wenn wir das hier unten öffnen und wir die Seite weiter runter gescrollt haben
Ah, das war natürlich klar, dass das nicht richtig funktioniert, nice, sehr schön, also wie immer
Okay, ich weiß, wie wir es machen, Leute, ich weiß, wie wir es machen, easy, easy, passt mal auf, easy fix
Easy fix, wir machen einfach das absolute, absolute Position
Absolute Position, das obere hier einfach, also Style gleich
Natürlich doof, dass wir jetzt hier keine CSS-Auto-Complete drin haben
Position, Absolute, Top, Nullpixel, kann man das auch, Bottom, Nullpixel, kann man das auch irgendwie abkürzen
Left, Nullpixel, Right, Nullpixel
So, jetzt haben wir Position, Absolute, das können wir jetzt gleich mal überprüfen, ob das noch funktioniert
Ja, das sieht doch schon mal, nee, Moment, wir wollen nicht Position, wir wollen Position Fixed haben
Position Fixed, was im Endeffekt heißt, dass es jetzt eigentlich richtig sein müsste, oder ist es jetzt richtig?
Oh, es ist prinzipiell richtig, aber, okay, Z-Index, alles klar, Z-Index
Okay, okay, nice, nice, nice, alles klar
Okay, Z-Index, alles klar, Z-Index, oh, okay, okay, nice, nice, nice, alles klar
Lad dir die ES6-String-HTML-Extension, dann hast du HTML-Sundags-Highlight-Eintritt
Oh, das ist nice, das ist gut, das brauche ich, das brauche ich, das ist wirklich praktisch hier für diesen Müll
Es funktioniert, wir haben ein Overlay, was nicht rumbackt, es Overlays, so wie es sein soll, easy
So, und jetzt, jetzt habe ich, jetzt habe ich noch eine andere Idee, also, jetzt müssen wir dafür sorgen,
dass wenn wir auf Cancel drücken, dass der ganze Kram wieder zugeht, das heißt, wir geben jetzt
dem Cancel, also, wie heißt die Extension, Extensions, was, ES6-String-HTML-ES6-Sundags-Highlighting-ES6-Multi-Line-String
Okay, nice, install
Ich muss bestimmt noch mal neu aufmachen,
ha? Muss ich, muss ich Ritual Studio Code neu starten? Nee, oder?
Äh, hier funktioniert nichts, hier ist nichts highlighted
Ja, also, es ist, äh, an Gplay
Ah, ich muss da HTML davor schreiben, oder was? Alter, ist das abfuck
Aha, habe ich jetzt da auch Sündags-Highlighting und sowas drinne, also kann ich jetzt sagen Style?
Nee, nee, das geht nicht, ne? Position, äh, das, es ist nur Highlighting, es ist sonst nichts
Aber immerhin, schon mal, schon mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen besser hier was durch, was zu erkennen
Okay, React Text brauchen wir nicht, Target W-Lan brauchen wir auch nicht, einfach nur W-Lan
Gut, nice, nice, nice, so jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie kriege ich das wieder weg,
wenn ich den Button drücke, das heißt unser, unser Close Button, unser Close Button,
der hier nicht wirklich gut zu erkennen ist, Cancel, die ganzen IDs muss ich hier noch rauswerfen,
sonst ist, sonst sind die Sachen im Zweifelsfall doppelt vorhanden, hier ist der Cancel Button
Button, ja, Cancel Button, so die ID ist, wie habe ich das Zeug hier genannt? Custom, nee,
jetzt heißt Custom DPSK Button, ja, okay mein Ding, das heißt jetzt Custom, also dieses ID kommt
weg hier schon mal, ist sonst doppelt, keine ID, so und der hier kriegt Cancel, der kriegt Custom
DPSK Button Cancel, so ganz toll, das brauchen wir, so und wie, wie kriege ich das jetzt wieder weg?
Weißt du, wie man Progress bei einem Webclient-Download als Task tracken kann für eine
Download-Fortschriftanzeige? Du meinst den, den C-Sharp Webclient oder im Browser?
Du meinst den HTTP Client oder den C-Sharp Webclient, im Webclient geht es glaube ich,
im HTTP Client geht es glaube ich nicht, aber das ist ein typischer Fall fürs Stack Overflow,
da wirst du es wahrscheinlich als auf Anime finden. Ja, also wenn es schon ein Event für
Download-Progress gibt, dann würde ich mal da drauf tippen, ja. So, wie kriege ich denn
jetzt zu diesem Button wieder einen Handler Attached? Also DIV, Query Selector, boah ist
das abartig, vielleicht nenne ich doch lieber AlpineJS oder sowas, weil das ist ja wirklich
mal hyper, hyper ppeger, oder? Vielleicht gucken wir uns das nächste Mal das dann mit AlpineJS an.
Das wirkt alles etwas angenehmer hier. Ich hoffe das geht übrigens direkt im Browser,
weil hier ist nichts mit Node.js und sowas. So, Query Selector Custom DPSK Button,
on, klick und jetzt, und jetzt mal mal Trick 17, passt mal auf. Wenn ich da drauf klicke,
dann sage ich nämlich einfach Document Body, nee, nee, nee, nee, DIV, Remove und jetzt sollte
ich bei dem Klick auf Cancel, sollte das Ding weggehen. Oh, Query Selector ist Null. Ah hier,
da fehlt Null. Pass mal auf, Cancel und Easy. Es close sich. Easy, easy. Wie unterscheidet
sich AlpineJS von anderen Frameworks? Ich habe keine Ahnung, außer dass es wirbt,
dass es besonders minimalistisch ist und ich glaube auch ohne Node direkt im Browser,
keine Ahnung. Ich habe es ja noch nicht verwendet. Es ist auch nicht so,
dass ich bei allen Web-Geschichten voll Bescheid weiß. Okay, das finde ich schon mal nice. Guck
mal, wir haben jetzt einen Dialog, der, okay hier noch nicht, der mit Cancel zugeht oder alternativ
beim Klick auf, wo ist hier der, wo ist denn hier der Header? Hier, Item E-Class. Das da. Boah,
das mit den IDs und diesem manuellen Attachement und so, das finde ich schon echt abartig. Kann
man mal was anderes, mal was anderes, kann man sowas hier machen? Das nicht als ID,
sondern als Class und jetzt einfach sagen, man möchte es an alle Classes Attachement,
kann man das so machen, dass es jetzt an alle Sachen in diesem Array Attached wird?
Das geht. Nee, das geht nicht. Query, Selector, All. Ah ja, okay, okay. Nee, jetzt geht es gar
nicht mehr. Muss ich danach noch dann trüben, muss ich danach noch loopen oder so? Query,
Selector, All. Attach, Listener, All. Nee, funktioniert nicht. Muss man da wirklich eine
Schleife machen? Gibt es da nichts Schöneres, irgendwas Eleganteres ohne Schleife? Ich meine,
ich könnte, ich könnte Filter machen, aber so wirklich schön ist das auch nicht. Ich könnte
Filter Element, das, das müsste ja dann, das müsste ja dann theoretisch gehen. Filter ist
not a Function. Ah nee, for, for, for each? Falls man das, falls man das loopen kann überhaupt.
Das geht. For each. Ja, ja, das ist, das ist okay, da kann ich mitleben so. Array from
Query, Selector, okay. So, guck mal Leute, wir haben jetzt sogar einen Dialog, in dem
man, in dem man, in dem man zumachen kann. Was, was will man denn noch mehr haben? Oder?
Also mehr, mehr braucht man doch eigentlich gar nicht. Einfach, einfach einen Closebar,
einen Dialog, das reicht schon. Jetzt, jetzt können wir aufhören, wir haben einen Dialog
dazugeht. Also ich finde, das ist äußerst Clean Code. Aber jetzt mal seriously Leute,
wie wollt ihr es anders machen? Mir fällt keine andere Möglichkeit ein, das hier drinnen.
Ich geh doch jetzt nicht ins Bett. The fuck, wir meinen das noch weiter. Wenn man ins Leere
klickt, oh nee, das interessiert mich, das interessiert mich nicht, das, das baue ich
jetzt nicht ein. Da müsste ich auf dem Background noch einen Listener Attach und es dann, dann
schließen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die eingebauten Pop-Ups das übrigens auch nicht
machen. Nö, die eingebauten Pop-Ups machen das auch nicht. Das ist nicht im Scope. Außerdem,
in welcher T-Shirt Größe ist denn deine Anforderung? So. So, was, was müssen wir als
Ding, eigentlich Leute, müssen wir jetzt eine Form bauen, weil da steht ja noch nichts
drinne. Da muss jetzt, da muss eine Form drinne, mit den W-Lans. Oh fuck, ich muss, shit, wie
kriege ich denn die W-Lans überhaupt raus, die es gibt? Wie kriege ich die W-Lans raus?
Valeroni, danke schön für den Sub. Da muss ich Fetchen, die muss ich Fetchen irgendwo
her. Api, Api Fetchen. Hit.
Ich probiere, man kann Klicks simulieren, ja das bringt mir ja noch nichts. Nö, nö,
nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö. Wir können mal kurz was gucken. Konsole, wo speichert
man, wo speichert man denn Global Variablen hier auf Window Element oder so? Vielleicht
speichern die das ja schon irgendwo für mich. Guck mal hier, da steht auch ganz viel, ganz
viel Shit drinne. Ah, das ist Dollar JQ ist jQuery, ok.
Such nach Const, Let oder Va? Hä? Steht doch da dann nicht als Const und Va
drinne. Komm mal, da stehen manchmal, da stehen manche
Sachen. Common? Hashtable Load? Was? Default Store? Das ist doch bestimmt React Shit oder?
Default Store? Ne, die gelieferte Seite ist, ist, ähm, irgendwelches
React Zeug, das, der Source Code wird uns da nichts bringen. Ist, ist das der, kriegt
man da irgendwas raus? Get State? Ich hab von React gar keine Ahnung. Also, was, was
ist denn? Ok, ok, Moment. Default Store. Was haben wir sonst noch? Getter? Last Commit
Info? Ah, was haben wir denn hier? Message? Was ist das? Atmen Status? Äh, Hilfe Messages
oder sowas? Ne, ich glaube. Alter, wie viel ist denn das? Monkeys? Angular, angenehme
alte React, ich hab keine Ahnung. Das sind, das sind einfach nur irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Strings, oder? Da steht, da steht nix Sinnvolles drin. Schauen wir mal wieder zu. Hallo? Äh,
Message Allow? Was haben die denn da alles drinstehen, man? Ne, ich glaube Filter bin
ich, glaub, weiß da gar nicht, was ich suchen soll. Was ist das? Version? Was machen die
denn da? Vela-Namen? Ja, können wir gleich machen. Sys-Menu? Talk? Ok. Client? Frame-Version?
Username? Atmen? Ja, super. Ok, Default Store, was macht man mit sowas? Object? GetState?
Ich, ich habe noch nie React verwendet. Wie verwendet man das? Also was ist das? Op-System-Config-Internet-Status?
Ach, guck mal da. Das sieht doch schon mal besser aus. Das sieht doch schon mal sinniger
aus. Gibt es da sowas wie WLAN-List oder sowas? List? W-W-Wi-Fi? WLAN-Stats? Die React-Extension?
Ja, schieß los. Welche? Wie heißt dies? Wie heißt das? WLAN-Croop-List. Ok, da steht
schon mal nichts drin. Das ist, das ist Poggers. Hier, WLAN-SVC-List. Length? Null. Ok. Ok.
Kann es sein, dass es einfach noch nicht geladen ist? Ok, wisst ihr was ich jetzt mache? Ich
mache jetzt mal einen Delay von 5000. Und jetzt gehen wir hier rein und stell... Fuck,
ich war zu langsam. Jetzt gehen wir hier rein und stellen sicher, dass es geladen ist. So.
Jetzt gucken wir nochmal. WLAN-SVC-List. Jetzt steht da was drin. Ha! Da stehen meine
WLANs drin. Easy. Wahrscheinlich leak ich jetzt mein WLAN-Passwort. Was haben wir denn
Schlimmes, weil das WLAN-Passwort ist eh aus. Also ich sag das jetzt nur, weil sonst wieder
Leute sagen, Max, leak, sich dann klipp von dem Passwort machen und so. Ich sag es euch
nur gleich, ja. Falls man das Passwort sieht, euch bringt das Passwort nichts. Das WLAN
ist ausgeschaltet. Das ist ein Test-Access-Point, der normalerweise nicht an ist. Und ich lösche
den Scheiß da nach E. Also ihr könnt das klippen, es wird euch aber nichts bringen
das zu klippen. Und steht das Passwort drinne? Das Passwort steht glaube ich gar nicht drinne,
oder? Doch hier, Passphrase. Passphrase steht drinne. Ok, nice. GG Eats. Passphrase. Aber
gut, das ist sehr nice. So hat man schon mal die ganzen WLAN-Infos. Das ist in der Tat
sehr praktisch. Da muss ich nicht selbst irgendwelche Get-Requests und Zeug machen. Das ist gut,
das ist gut. Ok, wo ist die React-Extension? Die Redux-Dev-Tools. Und das geht bei jeder
x-beliebigen Seite, auch wenn es nicht, wenn irgendwie Debug nicht eingeschaltet ist.
Moment, ich habe Firefox. Gibt es auch für Firefox? Security-mäßig bedenklich Passwörter
im Klartext zu speichern. Naja, ich würde mal fast sagen, das geht gar nicht viel anders
bei WLAN, oder? Die müssen auch überprüfen, ob das stimmt. Also, die müssen das ja. Ich
weiß nicht, ob du da einfach Hashes vergleichen kannst oder so. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Zumindest
speichern die das Ganze im Klartext. Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm in dem Fall, weil
du musst dich ja per Admin-Authentifiziert haben an der Kiste. Ansonsten, wenn jemand
dein Access-Point klaut und vielleicht die Firmware ausliest, oder ein Backup zieht oder
so. Keine Ahnung. So. Dev-Tools. Edit. Okay, a Kregel. Kurz hier rumschieben. Wo sind
die Dev-Tools? Ich würde das gerne pinnen. Darf ich das nicht pinnen? Und jetzt? Blöde
Frage. Was mache ich damit jetzt? Ach da! Nee, gibt es nicht. No store found. Das muss
man im Source-Code enden. Das haben die nicht gemacht. Das muss man glaube ich explizit
enable. Ich meine, ich kann mal reloaden, aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich kein Debug-Bild,
sondern vielleicht nutzen die auch gegen den anderen Store. Ja, möglich. Remove Extension.
Bäm. Naja, ist ja nicht schlimm. Wir kriegen diesen ganzen Krempel doch hier auch raus.
Hier. Da ist er doch. GetState und das was wir interessiert sind heißt WLAN SVC List.
WLAN SVC List. Also. Wo waren wir hier stehen geblieben? Ah, ich blicke nicht mehr durch,
das ist zu viel. GetState, ach da. So und wir wollen GetState, WLAN SVC List. Und? Ja,
5 Sekunden. Geht doch! Data, na. Ja gut, das ist daran, weil das noch nicht geladen hat,
aber wenn ich in diesem Menü bin, dann hat das geladen. Wobei ich zu langsam bin und
mir 5 Sekunden anscheinend nicht reichen, weil ich zu pepega bin, das zu finden. Guck,
jetzt hat das geladen. Data. Ja, genau das brauche ich. Ok, also will ich, Data will
ich noch haben. Data. Sehr schön, das gefällt mir. Das heißt im Endeffekt, kriege ich die
ganzen Daten jetzt ausgelesen aus diesem React Store. Soll mir recht sein. Achtung, Data
Array. Da ist es doch, guck. Die ganzen WLANs, SSIDs, bla bla bla blub. Wunderbar. Alles
was man braucht. Ein WPA Object mit noch mehr Pass Phrases drin. WPA Object, Pass Phrase,
Pass Phrase, so viel Pass Phrase. Limit, DPSK, Enabled, Pass Length. Genau das, was ich
brauche. Also heißt im Endeffekt, WLAN, Data gleich. Jetzt können wir mal ein ordentliches
Java Script Objekt da draus machen, irgendwie Let, keine Ahnung, Store, Data, Let, WLANs
oder WLANs, WLANs, WLANs, WLANs ist ok. So, also was brauchen wir da? Wir brauchen den
Name, ne Moment, wir brauchen ja mehrere Sachen. Moment, Moment, Moment, wir brauchen ja mehrere
Sachen. Wir brauchen den Name vom WLAN, es könnte ja mehr als ein WLAN sein. Wir brauchen,
also wir brauchen die ID, wir brauchen den Namen. So, der Rest ist erstmal wurscht. Und
dann brauche ich hier irgendwo, das kenne ich noch, wo ich das CLI gebastelt habe, also
Pass Phrase brauche ich nicht. Was ich brauche ist Dynamic PSK und Dynamic PSK Length. Die
zwei Sachen brauche ich. So, heißt im Endeffekt, wir nehmen jetzt Store Data, Map, wir nehmen
quasi alle Sachen, jedes Element aus dem Array, nennen wir das mal WLAN, so, WLAN,
so und daraus machen wir jetzt ein Objekt, das besteht aus Name, ich glaube das heißt
das heißt so einfach Name, Name, ID, kann man eigentlich, kann man sowas in Java Script
machen, wenn ich will, dass der Name der gleiche ist, einfach so. Also in C Sharp geht das,
also so, dann. Weiß nicht, ob das hier auch funktioniert. Und dann will ich DPSK Länge,
Moment, macht man das jetzt so, ja, WLAN, WPA, Dynamic PSK Length, ok, Console Log,
und bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das jetzt tut. Jetzt muss ich den Mist, den Mist wieder
anklicken, aber gut, was willst du machen. Oh, schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert. Natürlich
hat es jetzt nicht funktioniert. Und warum nicht? Keine Ahnung. Warum hat es nicht funktioniert?
Hätte eigentlich funktionieren müssen, Debuggen, wie soll ich hier was Debuggen? Länge 1 undefined,
warum? Macht man das mit dem Doppelpunkt? Nee. Klicke in der Konsole auf den, ja, ok
und dann. Ach so, du meinst, ja, ach ja, das meinst du hier. Und wo sehe ich jetzt,
was da wie zugewiesen ist? Gar nicht, oder? So haffern, haffern kann ich nicht. Ok, Leute,
wir machen das nächste Mal weiter. Ich muss mal ganz dringend aufs Klo und in der Viertelstunde
ist eh Bettgetim. Wir sehen uns, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, ich muss mal dringend
wohin. Machts gut, wir sehen uns, bis dann, see you.